Okay. We're going to go ahead and reconvene on to item 15 public hearings. Item a public
hearing to consider the establishment of city of Ripavalli Community Facilities District
number 2024-1, the district city and community facilities district number 2024-2, the district
facilities continued from the August 15th meeting, 2024 meeting.
Mr. Mayor?
Yes.
Oh, I just need to make an announcement for this hearing.
Councilmember Altamorano will not participate on item 15a, the formation of two community
facility districts to fund public improvements, community benefit contributions, and public
services for the district at Ripavalli project.
Councilmember Altamorano owns property near the district at Ripavalli boundaries, the Fair
Political Practices Commission issued an opinion stating that she cannot participate in council
decisions on matters relating to the district at Ripavalli specific plan and implementation
of the project.
Councilmember Altamorano will leave the council chamber while this matter is being discussed
and voted on. The minutes for this meeting will also show my comments explaining her conflict
and confirming that she did not participate in this decision.
Okay. Mr. Schup, may we have your staff report on this item?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Miss Schup.
Sorry. It's only my second time up here.
Good evening, Mayor, Mayor Pro Tem, council members. I'm here this evening to present for
you some information related to the district CFDs that we'll be putting forth for formation
this evening.
The presentation available? I have a short PowerPoint for you.
Great. Thank you.
Introductions. I am here. My name is Heidi Schappie. I'm the President and Managing Director
of Web Municipal Finance and with me is my associate Brent Howard as well as other members
of the financing team, Mark Pressman, your municipal advisor, and Brad Neal. He is your
bond council. We're going to go over introductions, which I've done, some of the development agreement
provisions, the overview of the two CFDs, next steps, and then open the floor for any questions
you may have.
So the CFDs that are being presented this evening are being formed pursuant to provisions
of the development agreement. So first we will discuss CFD 2024-1, which is the city CFD
that provides for the provisions of the development agreement that are of benefit to the city.
CFD 2024-1 will have five separate special taxes that are described in the rate method
of apportionment. The first special tax will provide for city facilities. So city infrastructure
that will allow for bonds to be issued for the proceeds of those bonds to benefit city
infrastructure needs. The special tax C&D to go in order of items being provided will provide
for maintenance within the development of the district. So maintenance that the city will
be taking on as a result of the development of the district will be funded through special
tax B and C. Special tax B is maintenance LB provided by the city. Special tax D will
be a contingent special tax where maintenance services will be provided by the community
association, but should the services being provided not meet the needs of the city or
desires of the city for a level of maintenance, the city would have a funding mechanism to step
in and provide those maintenance items if needed. Special tax B, which is the annual public
safety special tax, provides for revenue for the city to provide public safety services
from the district development. And special tax E is a special tax that is for the light
industrial portion of the district development and it's the five cents per square foot we're
calling it the city services special tax that will provide for additional road maintenance
requirements being incurred to the city by the district development. So to recap the city's
special tax for facilities will pay for city infrastructure, public safety facilities with
a not to exceed bonded indebtedness of six million dollars and the services will pay for
public safety, infrastructure maintenance, roadway and landscape maintenance if necessary
and an additional tax for specifically road maintenance. This is a overview of the projected
annual revenue for each of the five special taxes. Again, the maintenance services contingent
would only be levied if necessary, but this provides a city with an annual revenue of 125,000
at build out for facilities, public safety at 492, 157 at build out on an annual basis,
maintenance services at around 165,000 to provide for the maintenance of the district
development. And then for your additional road maintenance on the light industrial is 75,000.
Here is a boundary of the district CFD. So these are all the properties within the CFD that
will be paying the special tax. There are a couple of NAP sections that will be annexed at a future
date once ownership is attained. CFD 2024-2 is the second CFD being formed as a part of the
development agreement. The city is forming the CFD to fund infrastructure improvements being
put in by the developer. This will project into finance, off-site street improvements,
on-site street improvements, frontage street improvements, intersection improvements and traffic
signals. This puts the cost burden for these improvements on the property owners and has a not
to exceed bonded indebtedness of 45 million. The annual revenue for the CFD is projected to be
$1.8 million to generate that $45 million approximate bond issuance depending on economics
at the time of the bond issuance. And then you'll see the allocation of the special tax
to each of these types of land uses. There is a same boundary map but for this CFD that's on
behalf of the developer and the next steps. So we have completed the approval of the resolution
of intention which brought us to this evening which is your public hearing where the city staff
is recommending approval of the resolutions assuming a positive election result and the ordinances
for the formation of these CFDs. Then following this you'll have a second reading of the ordinance
assuming approval on September 19th. Questions. Thank you very much. Do we have any questions up here?
You want to go start? Yeah go ahead. I just wanted to ask that if all of the items in the
developer agreement that pertain to special assessments are included in this or has anything
been left out and if so why? All of the items within the development agreement that can be funded
through a CFD have been included in the CFD in so far as including the city services component
for light industrial and really just to provide a streamline mechanism for the city to collect
those items. Okay thank you. And just to understand the rates so if you go back to the slide where
the rates are where you have the tax A and E it says that on the city services the special tax E
for light industrial which is the warehouses that are being built here in the district
that are in light industrial land use obviously. 5 cents per square foot it seems very low
and it's generating $75,000 that's per year annually. And what if the more than 500 trucks a day that
are going to be utilized in this the 40 acres or 70 acres I think of warehouses? What if the
damage the street damage is more than that? Who would pay for that? That's a good question. The
5 cents per square foot was a rate that was negotiated and was put into the development
agreement so if that revenue is not sufficient I would defer maybe to Rod to answer that question.
Who pays Rod who pays for let's just say the 75,000 isn't enough who would pay for additional
damage to the streets? Yeah so that would probably become an obligation of the city's general fund
if there weren't other revenue sources specifically for street repair. The 75,000 was designed
to based on an assumption or an estimate of what the street impacts would be from the truck
generation at that project. For a year and if at some point we need to repave the streets
that would be covered by the taxpayers? Yeah most of our repaving work in
Group of Valley comes from either gas tax revenue that we get from the state and of course that's
ultimately paid by taxpayers or the SB1 revenues that come from the state as well and that's also
state revenue that comes to us from Sacramento for a variety of street and road improvements
or like the surprise ARPA funds that we had a couple years ago and any additional funding.
And then Heidi on the second CFD and I know we talked about this last week and I wanted to
just get some clarity so basically the city we're authorizing a bond of up to $45 million so that
the developer can actually build so we're authorizing the financing of the property that's going to be
on the backs of the current land or guaranteed by the land and by the residents correct?
It would be guaranteed by the property within the boundaries of the district development so most of
that is considered non-residential. There is one component that's multifamily residential
which will be apartments that will be paying into that as well as the city CFD. The owner of the
apartment the owner of the property would pay that and how they choose to put that onto
the rent or what have you would be up to them but yeah it would be secured by the property.
So the owner is responsible for it but in terms of the CFD breakdown really the residents are
going to pay for it. The property owners within the development are going to pay for it so.
So the people who purchase homes there the property owners there?
There wouldn't be any residential homes within the development of the district
as of what we have designed for the plan. There isn't planned to be any single-family residential
homes. Oh godly residential. I meant the residential component the residents yeah I understand.
And it is important to point out for those bonds that those will never become an obligation of the
city's general fund even if there was a default or you know something that went
went wrong down the road the city is never going to be on the hook to pay those bonds back.
Okay we're we're just authorizing them to to we're authorizing that our the residents can
will guarantee it. That's correct. Okay. Got it. Thank you Heidi. That's all I have.
Yeah. I'm going to go ahead and open it to the public hearing.
I don't have any speaker court on that. Do we have anything in there? No.
Okay so with that then I'll close the public hearing. Peter do we have to read all the
resolutions on here? No specific order in which you have to take them in.
So will there be no for the public? Okay. So now we'll move on to Miss Wasko. May we have
tabulations on the ballot? I think before this you you would need to adopt resolution numbers
85 and 86. Oh correct. Yeah so we'll call a motion for in a second to adopt resolution number 2024
dash 85 and 2024 dash 86. Move to approve. Second. All in favor.
All right. I'll vote no. I think this is a resident subsidy of our developers profits.
I'm going to vote no thank you. Thank you. Miss Wasko school may we have the
tabulations of the ballot? Yes one owner cast one ballot. All votes cast were in favor of the
special taxes. Thank you very much. I also call for a motion and second to adopt resolution 2024
dash 87. Move to approve. Second. All in favor. All right. No. All opposed. No.
I'm going to item five. Motion and a second to introduce ordinance number 2024 dash 17. Move to
approve. Second. All in favor. All in favor. All in favor. All in favor. All in favor. All in favor. All in
opposed. Okay. Miss Wasko may we have a tabulation of the ballot on that one? Yes one owner cast one
ballot. All votes cast were in favor of the special taxes. Thank you.
Onto item eight. May we have a motion and a second to adopt resolution number 2024 dash 90.
Move to approve. Second. All in favor. All in favor. All opposed. Opposed.
And then onto item nine. Second and a motion and a second to introduce number 2024 dash 18.
Order number 2024 dash 18. That's the last one. Yes. Yes. Yes. Mm-hmm. Cool. So just one comment before I
make the motion. As a reminder, old developments that there are either the residents or commercial
or industrial tenants are the ones that pay for the added infrastructure and not the current
residents. That's what this is. Move to approve. Second. All in favor. All in favor. All opposed.
Thank you very much. We'll move on to item 10. I mean yes. Item nine. Oh ten.
It was cut off. Does that also? And I don't have ten on my staff report.
It's cut off on this one. It's in the recommended action. Move to approve. Second. All in favor. All
in favor. All in favor. All in favor. All opposed. Opposed. Okay. Onto item B. Can someone call
Leslie back in? Okay. Now there was only nine items. Okay. Thank you very much. Onto item B.
Public hearing to consider the real VISTA specific plan, project master application, MA number 16045,
general plan amendment, GPA 16001, real VISTA specific plan, SP 16001,
development agreement, DA16001, and tentative, track TTM 37074 and TTM 38639, project certifying
an environmental impact report making findings, adopting a statement overriding considerations
and adopting a mitigation monitoring and reporting program for real VISTA specific plan that would
permit development of up to 1697 new residential units, 1,269,774 square feet of light industrial
land use, 1,428,768 square feet of business park land use, 510.8 acres of natural open space,
14.3 acres of park and recreational amenities, and 13.4 public school site. Project location
generally located north of state route SR60, south of city, northern boundary line, and between
Armstrong and Road, and Rubida Boulevard, APN's 175-160-001, 177-030-014, 177-040-002,
177-040-008, 175-080-010, 175-090-001, 171-090-003, 175-090-004, 177-060-012, 175-160-007, 175-160-005,
175-100-005, 175-100-006, 175-150-002, 175-100-003, applicant, rich and planned community is inked,
continued from the August 15th, 2024 meeting. Mr. Patches, may we have your staff report on the
side and please. Thank you, Mr. Mayor. Members of the City Council, Jim Patches, Principal Planner,
tonight I will be reviewing the Rio Vista specific plan proposal. Project is located in the northwestern
corner of the city, shown on the maps, surrounded by residential, some industrial and commercial
uses. This is the pictures of the existing site, as you can see it's vacant right now.
It includes some hilly terrain and there's been kind of a history of off-road vehicle use and
illegal trash dumping on the site which has been an issue for the current owner.
Project description, this is a proposed specific plan on 917 acres, it includes a mixture of
uses, residential, light industrial, a school site, and community park and recreational uses.
There's two tentative track maps proposed and the specific plan replaces the existing Rio Vista
specific plan number two, four, three, if approved, which was adopted by Riverside County in 1992.
There are basically four entitlements in order to approve the project involved. There's a general
plan amendment basically making land uses consistent with the proposed specific plan.
The specific plan itself, which I mentioned replaces the existing specific plan,
and introduces new land uses and development standards and planning requirements.
There's a development agreement between the city and the applicant that provides community benefits
in exchange for certain protections for the developer and again there's two tentative
maps which I mentioned earlier. This slide compares the existing specific plan to
the proposed specific plan. The residential numbers, the dwelling needs remains the same,
which is required by state law. However, it's quite a lower amount of area than the existing
specific plan. There is no commercial use proposed in a new specific plan so the five acres goes away,
added are a business park of 92 acres, and 54 acres of light industrial. There's approximately
100 additional acres of open space due to the reduction of residential area. There's a school
site of the previous specific plan had two school sites that based on discussions with the school
district that was only one was really necessary so that was reduced to one. And then we'll talk
about this in greater detail, but there's a Palmer Oak buffer existing specific plan that would
only be about 80 feet in the proposed it's 450 feet. This is just kind of a show of the difference of
the land area and the reduction of land area between the two specific plans.
As far as residential uses, there's the mixture as I said, the yellow,
light yellow is very low, about two units per acre, and then kind of in contrast the highest
density is 25 in the dark brown, 25 to only needs per acre, and kind of everything in between.
As far as non-residential land uses, some of the key aspects is the community park.
Open space, which I mentioned, is 510 acres. There's a public facility school district,
which is planning area 18. That particular area is slated for a school site to be developed.
The school district has it up to the 800th dwelling unit completion to make a decision on whether to
move forward with that school. Should they not move forward, and it wasn't, which would be based on
basically a school need. If that wasn't necessary, then they could revert to other land uses,
which would be approved by the city. Potentially, there could be 54 residential units or commercial
or recreational other public use that the community wouldn't see a need for.
Then there's also, as we previously said, a business park and light industrial area.
As far as circulation, the circulation plan creates a hierarchy of streets for traffic
circulation within the project and outside the project. It extends, one of the kind of that,
the heart of it or the artery of the whole circulation system is the extension of 20th Street
between Sierra Avenue and Rubido Boulevard, which serves as the backbone for the project,
but also provides a needed enhancement to the city's overall circulation.
As far as freeway connections, there's connectivity to the 60 freeway through Armstrong, Rubido Boulevard
and Market Street. There's also provisions within the plan for truck travel. The plan restricts
truck traffic from extending eastward toward Shadow Rock area
and directs it towards the 20th Street toward Rubido Boulevard and the industrial area of the
project. As far as the circulation plan, one of the provisions to prevent truck traffic to
proceed east is there's an aroundabout plan, which makes it difficult for trucks to enter and go
beyond that point. There's the 20th Street improvements. There's two cross sections here.
The improvement is a four-lane road, 130 feet in width. That includes equestrian trails,
pedestrian and bicycle trails on one side of the road. There's also provisions for collector and
local roads, which will provide the circulation within the different planning areas. Those roads
will be determined in terms of their design and location as the planning areas move forward.
Another important aspect are three emergency accesses, particularly for PA1. That emergency access
not only has the function of providing a police and fire access in the event of an emergency,
but has an electronic gates that the fire department controls that could be opened
as an evacuation route should be needed for the residents of that area.
As far as open space and recreation, natural open space again is 510 acres, which is about
50 or 58% of the total site. Again, approximately 100 acres more than the existing specific plan.
There's also an extensive trail system for equestrians, bicyclists and pedestrians included.
That includes hard and soft surface pavement. The trail system is open to both the residents
of the specific plan, but also the public. So there's two trailheads proposed and you can see them and
see if I can, one's located right here and the other's located right here on map. I'm going to do that
again. So here and here, those trailheads will be improved for parking for community residents.
It could also include horse trailers and other recreational needs would be addressed in those
improvements. And those would be developed with the different planning areas as we move forward.
The open space plan also includes a community park which is a little over 14 acres and it would
include sports fields and different recreational needs such as playgrounds and so forth, picnic
amenities, both passive and active spaces. And it is required to be completed by the 600
dwelling unit of the project. There's also neighborhood parks that are included. There'll be
five distributed through the planning areas and those will be improved with the planning areas
developments. They average about an acre in size and they're required to be improved or completed
and open to the public with the 75th percentile of the homes being completed. And then finally,
planning area nine which is the high density residential includes apartments which would have
recreational amenities such as a clubhouse and a swimming pool. Then there's a phasing plan.
There's four phases to the project. The tentative track maps are basically completing the
phase one in blue there for 425 residential units. It also includes the community park
being developed as I said by the 600 dwelling unit. Also the neighborhood parks being developed
with the planning areas and there's a provision that light industrial development can't occur
until at least 170 of the residential units have been completed. The maintenance plan basically
distributes maintenance between the property owners which are required to take care of their own
private lots and the parkway in front of their houses. There's a master association for both
the residents and the industrial and business parks. They're required to take care of all
the common areas, parkways, open spaces and private drives. RCSD will be facilitating and
maintaining water and wastewater services. The city would be required to do public streets,
public facilities and infrastructure and then there's also provisions for the local conservation
organization to maintain the open space and that includes a provision for a $250,000
endowment which is included in the DA and also homeowner association fees that would provide
long-term and perpetuity maintenance of the open space areas. As far as public safety,
Cal Fire and Riverside County Fire Departments will provide fire services. They're requiring
funding for an addition of two personnel and one apparatus at Fire Station 18. Basically that
is a paramedic unit being added to that facility. County Sheriff's Department provides public
services for the project or I mean police services sorry for the project and this will be
these improvements and services will be paid for through a CFD and in the development agreement
of $550,000 annually for public safety. In terms of the residential, this is just a slide that
demonstrates the different layouts for the different products. They include specific residential
standards for each of the residential land uses being proposed and this slide just shows you what
the product types would look like for kind of a single family style homes, the cluster developments
and then the apartment buildings. The specific plan includes design guidelines and objective
design standards for the development of high quality architecture and identifies five residential
styles Victorian, Craftsman, California bungalow, California ranch and American farmhouse. Each
residential development is required to provide at least three different styles within their
development. Same goes for the light industrial and business park and includes the development
standards and setbacks for each. The land uses for both require either a site development
permit or a CUP, conditional use permit for approval. They're primarily light industrial
types of uses, industrial manufacturing and research and development requirements that
storage be completely within a building. Transportation and utilities and transit stops are
allowed eating and drinking establishments such as breweries typically seen in some
business parks in the area. Open space and recreation are also allowed uses and trails will
be intersecting with portions of the business park. Also professional offices, retail services and
educational uses that as you recall the tech center originally was part of kind of the consideration
of this project. Although it's not currently a part of it, it isn't allowed use within the project.
It should also be noted that answer uses to any of the principal uses may be approved as part of
the discussion rate process which could include storage, fleet maintenance or other uses necessary
for the operation of the principal use. Also it's important to note that warehouse distribution is
not allowed as part of the specific plan land uses and the site development and condition
use process will evaluate each project to make sure that warehouse distribution isn't somehow
snuck in. In addition with a change of use there's a city evaluation through the business
registration application review that would prevent such uses to kind of filter in over time.
The business park also includes its own design guidelines that maintain a high quality design
throughout. Likewise for landscape design guidelines this applies to all improvements within
the community so residential utilities everything has certain landscape design guidelines that
they're required to meet that are both drought tolerant and heavily weighed on native plantings.
There's includes with provisions for interfaces with open space areas and it includes fuel
modifications and so special plants that are both drought tolerant but also fire resistant.
As far as the general plan amendment as I touched on this is the one on the left is the
existing general plan designations for the specific plan area and the one on the right is the proposed
this basically matches what the specific plan is proposing and if approved the general plan
and the specific plan to be consistent with one another so that's what's being proposed in the
amendment. As far as the development agreement just in general it provides owner vested rights
to proceed with development of the site in accordance to the design defined policies and
regulations and ensures cities secure certain public benefits to enhance the community and it
provides for employment growth increased tax revenues stimulates the economy growth in the
community in the surrounding site and into cheese general plan goals in terms of investment in
the community. It's a term of 20 years and is estimating the total community of benefits just
a little shy of 22 million dollars and for this next three slides I'd like to turn it over to our
consultant and help us with the development agreement that's Brandon Fender so Brandon can you come up?
Thank you Jim. Good evening Mayor Pro Tem and City Council. Brandon Fender with RSG we are a
consultant to the city. We advise city staff on the community benefits and the development
agreement. There's a number of community benefits built into the development agreement.
I'm going to go through this on the next couple slides here. So first we have three CFDs public
safety and a facility CFD. Those as Jim mentioned those will yield the city about half a million
dollars with the facility CFD and about five hundred fifty seven thousand dollars a year for the public
safety CFD. The maintenance CFD we don't have a value associated with that that'll be based on the
actual maintenance of the improvements on the site. We have a one-time general municipal services
contribution total 1.4 million dollars. We have a one-time contribution. I'm out of order here.
The DA has commercial truck enforcement so the owner and the lessees of the commercial space on
the site will be required to will require trucks that are servicing the site to follow the city's
commercial truck rules and the city will be responsible for funding that enforcement. The
owner and the lessees will be responsible for following those rules. The city has first right
of refusal on planning area 14. That's as Jim mentioned the business park that was potentially
or could potentially be designated for a technical school, trade school in the future.
We have equestrian facilities a contribution of three hundred twenty five thousand dollars
that's for new and existing maintenance of existing equestrian facilities in the city.
We have the master planning activities in the Rubino area a contribution of two hundred thousand
dollars that's a one-time contribution. The Palmer's Oak land and endowment so we're showing the
endowment value here of two hundred fifty thousand dollars. This also allocates the open space
that contains the Palmer's Oak and that's a one-time contribution and then there's also an
administrative fee built into the development agreement. Thank you Brandon. So now I'd like to
touch on the two track maps. There's a finance map that includes subdivisions of land that convey
the title of the land. It creates 26 large lots on nine hundred and seven point two acres for
finance purposes only. There's no improvements involved and it does not create any legal building
sites. Do we know why the lights going off? So there's two recommended changes to the specific
plan. In the objective standards the city wanted to see a one-story requirement for development
even though this is higher density and higher density product for lots their thirteen hundred
square feet are larger and the developer had a lot of issues with that because of just site
planning and being able to get a house big enough to sell. So we worked with the developer and we
came up with a compromise that would allow what's called pop-top homes which are basically single
family homes with attic improvements so that way they were able to get some second story space
up to 40 percent of the lower story and still achieve that look that the city was requesting and
providing some variation of development within the residential areas. So this compromise wording
has come was developed and the city is a support of this change and it's included in your attachment
eight of your staff report and the resolutions. There's also just a typo that we noticed so we're
requesting and we added this to the changes on one particular part of the standards it listed the
wrong boundary as planning area 14 which isn't adjacent to the other boundaries so it didn't make
sense so we corrected that. Now just briefly to describe the environmental impact report the draft
EIR was circulated a 45-day review period between October 19th and January 5th that's more than 45
days there was a small extension added to it because of the holidays and then the EIR scope included
19 key areas including aesthetics, air quality, biology, cultural resources, energy, greenhouse
gases, land use and planning, transportation and traffic, tribal cultural resources and wildfire
among others. Through the analysis of the EIR it was found that there are significant environmental
impacts for air quality, greenhouse gases, historic and archaeological resources and tribal and
cultural resources and because of that it requires a statement of overwriting considerations in
order to approve the project which basically states how the benefits of the project outweigh the
impacts that the project would cause. Next I'd like to talk about the polymer preservation
measures just quickly it's a shrub oak that it's native to California and Baja it stands between
two and three meters in height and it reproduces itself both through acorns and cloning and because
of the cloning aspect of it this particular tree is estimated between 13,000 to 18,000 years old.
It's also it's one of the oldest known organisms in California and the third oldest on earth
it's cultural importance is it's a medicine tree for the Keish nation and it's location is in the
open space conservation area in a steep rocky terrain the recommended buffer based on our technical
analysis that were completed is 259 feet the extended buffer is 450 feet of non-developable area
in addition to another 100 feet to the closest building making that 550 feet in addition it's
located 150 feet higher to the closest pad elevation
and then there's also some provisions for a conveyance of land to a non-profit entity which is
we're working with the Keish nation on that or the developer is and as we mentioned earlier it was
a $250,000 endowment and a homeowner association fee that would run long-term for the long-term
preservation of the property the open space just to mention briefly the Keish nation's involvement
they've been engaged in this process of consultation through SB 18 and AB 52 since 2018 they have
submitted a sacred land files to the state for a portion of the project site long before the project
the Native American Commission is sacred lands inventory indicates that tribes is considered
a project site to contain tribal cultural resources of special religious and social
significance since incorporation has been provided with the city with they've been involved with the
tribe and continuing cultural ties to group of valley and its traditional heritage and they have
expertise regarding tribal historic and history and practices and is the only tribe who is recognized
the I don't know how to say that herungruna oak or what we call the palmer oak and as a sacred
and an extremely important resource for them so there's as I mentioned several studies that have
occurred and I wanted to say that we have the biologist Mike Tuma who can go into more detail on
any of these should there be questions there's a hydrogeologic investigation that was done in
January 2022 that basically did field investigations and found the groundwater was quite a ways below
the shrub of 90 feet and in basically surmised that there must be others some other catchment in the
rock fractures that provide a water source during the drought seasons so to either confirm that or
refute that there was a ground penetration radar study that basically did radar analysis underground
and that confirmed that there indeed is a basin shaped depression not far under the subsurface of
the bedrock that allows water collection that could sustain the oak and dry periods then the
next question was well okay if there is this rock formation we not only don't want to harm the tree
but we don't want to harm the rock formation so there was a vibration study done that assessed what
construction impacts might have to the rock formation and the tree and it determined the
vibrations from the largest equipment and construction needs to be at least a distance of
259 feet away not to harm the subsurface bedrock and that led to the first buffer of 259 feet
further through the planning commission review there was a root investigation
there was known our our consultant team our environmental consulting team could find known
non-invasive way to map the root system so they relied on literature review root characteristics
and the key findings are that it's three to six times the above ground biomass
and then it's at a depth that approximates 30 feet and the lateral extension is
16 feet beyond the outer edge of the the oak there was also some review of potential heat island
effects which was brought up and asked to be reviewed by the planning commission
and the study well first of all heat island effect ascribes higher temperatures in urban
and suburban areas due to solar heat absorbed by buildings roads parking lots and machinery
L&L consulting did a subsurface temperatures of the bedrock and oak and found that it could exceed
150 or 120 degrees Fahrenheit in the summer and the asphalt conditions of the potential
development could be about 120 and 150 Fahrenheit also there's requirements within the project
and conditions of approval of the future development have to has to provide cool pavement
a minimum of 15 percent landscaping native plants with trees and the parking areas also
the project as a whole as you can see from the the graphic there contains over 59 percent of
open space area the overall conclusion is the additional heat from the project's infrastructure
being over actually 450 feet away would likely have an insignificant effect on the area surrounding
the oak and the oak is also surviving in already very high conditions due to the
surrounding rock and temperatures of 120 degrees Fahrenheit
so the planning commission review on this project was conducted over three public hearings
the final one on July 24th 2024 where they recommended the city council the approval of the real
VISTA specific plan the environmental impact report the statement of overriding considerations
mitigation monitoring program and findings of fact so i'm going to turn this over to Joe for the next
section thank you mr mary and council members so i'm just going to be providing a project summary
here obviously this has been a very extensive report the reason for that is because of really
the enormity the scope the complexity of this project but when you boil it down it really is
because of all of that because of its size and everything the activation of this is a very very
significant development within the city it's a very large vacant site it really has the potential
to be a transformative project particularly for the surrounding area the reason for this is
because number one it represents a very significant private investment into the area we're talking
about new major street and utility improvements that would be associated with the project
expansion of the open space area from the currently approved specific plan new housing
opportunities as well as additional residents who can economically support not only local businesses
but make it easier for the city to attract new high quality businesses into the community there
will also be new one time as well as permanent jobs as part of the light manufacturing and
business park components of the project it will also eliminate several of the public
nuisances that Jim had mentioned early on in his presentation as well as public safety issues this
includes off-roading activities fires homelessness as well as illegal dumping which is a continual
problem in the area there's also investment in parks youth activities and equestrian amenities
on this point I would like to elaborate a little bit on what Brandon indicated in the slides when he
was talking about the development agreement community benefits there was a section that talked
about three hundred twenty five thousand dollars that just to be specific that was something that
the planning commission reviewed that is money that would be provided to JRPD for the improvement
of new and existing parks and or equestrian amenities and or youth activities that directly
impact the rubido the communities of rubido and sunny slope areas so I just want to be specific and that's
the language that will be included in the development agreement the project also enhances
the connectivity by extending 20th Street from Sierra over to rubido which is a very very important
connection element to the project there are also and when we talk about business park and light
industrial components of the project this really makes the other aspects of the development possible
because of the revenue that is generated from those that allows that major infrastructure to go
into the site and I just wanted to reiterate once again a very important point that when we
talk about business park and light industrial we're not talking about warehouse uses or logistics
those uses in terms of warehouse and logistics are prohibited the Palmer Oak Conservation issue is
extremely important there's been a great deal of time and effort and and energy that has been
devoted to protecting this critical and valuable biological historical and cultural resource
there've been extensive studies that have been done to determine ways to best protect this
that currently do not exist with the existing specific plan so one of those is as Jim indicated
an expanded buffer this has expanded in terms of the amount of feet and distancing over the course
of the several public hearings that were held by the planning commission so the buffer zone is now
450 feet to the nearest development area and 500 feet from the nearest building there's also
interim preservation and maintenance measures to protect the tree there's also conveyance of land
to a conservation entity in this case one of the Native American tribes and this would be for not
only the short term but also the long-term preservation of this valuable resource as part of the conservation
area there's also an initial endowment and long-term ongoing funding for the preservation and maintenance
of this conservation area and the Palmer Oak in terms of economic development this project serves
as an important economic engine to provide critical city-wide services this includes street and drainage
improvements as well as police and fire services this is both on one time as well as ongoing revenue
streams that currently do not exist in the in the community and they will serve to benefit the
community in several ways including through public safety services and finally it will support the
city's housing goals so it not only helps us to meet the state's regional housing requirements
but also this project will be subject to the city's existing inclusionary housing ordinance
which would provide up to 119 affordable units on site or up to 7.5 million dollars in in
loofies that and this would be revenue that could be leveraged and used by the city to provide
affordable housing and I will now pass it off to Jim to finish off with the recommendation
so to finish off the recommendation this is a recommending adoption of the resolution to
certify the environmental impact report findings of fact in adopting a statement of
overriding considerations and a mitigation monitoring program to the adoption of resolution
approving GPA 16001 specific plan 16001 and the alternative pages that I mentioned in attachment
8 as well as repealing the existing real VISTA specific plan number 243 and
proving tentative track maps number 38639 and 37074 and then finally introducing an ordinance
number 202423 approving the involvement agreement between the city and richland communities
so that concludes the presentation thank you very much for that report do we have any questions
for staff yeah I have questions thank you thank you Jim and Joe and Brandon for the presentation
one of the things I noticed about this presentation versus the planning commission is there there wasn't
a line about trucks I know in the planning commission presentation there was a line that said about
814 trucks would be coming in and out to the light industrial do we have that estimate or has that
changed there's been no change and we do have Manny Gonzalez in the audience from our engineering
department who can discuss those truck issues yeah okay yeah I just have some quick questions
of Manny's here amen thank you members of the city council I will be a different member
and Manny is here too to back up so thank you guys so Paul I know we're we don't have a specific
project in the light industrial area so this is all really estimate right but how many trucks
are we anticipating that is going to come in and out of this project
Council member Carmona we are expecting based on the traffic impact analysis 814 truck traffic
daily truck traffic okay and this is for the 50 acres of light industrial or is it collectively
with the business park yeah it is the total truck traffic for this project okay for 140 acres that
is correct okay and then do we know do we have an estimate of how many truck docks would come in
a in the light in the industrial section yeah that depends upon the design when we get the detail
design we do not have that information now okay so that'll come from the design and and how is this
estimate drawn up Paul just just for the benefit of all of our residents and just so I get a
clear idea yeah this is the standard traffic industry we have the city standards where we
calculate all the based on the zoning and the use so there is a book of traffic engineers which
we calculate based on the square footage of each development nature of the development whether
it's a residential commercial industrial business park so there is a criteria which is used across
across the board in California okay so warehouse warehouse has a term or as a use is prohibited
but there's still going to be significant truck impacts yeah truck council member like I mentioned
the truck traffic generated from this project is 814 that's the estimated truck traffic got it is
there and this might be a planning question but is there a limit on how many would be allowed in
the future or is that just depending on what type of project comes in yeah basically on this one
this is what the specific plan calls for if there's any change the numbers might change like that
if there is any amendment to the specific plan that has to come back to the city council got it okay
great and then thank you Paul I think I'm going to go back to the planning team
questions on the use is permitted in the light industrial obviously we know that the term
warehouse will not be used today there wouldn't be a lot to build warehouses but
one of the permitted uses I saw is says storage within buildings what does that imply or what does
that tell us so so the land use includes manufacturing and all manufacturing uses include warehouse
because you have to have a place to put the goods to come in to make this whatever you're making
and also a place to store to take it out right okay so okay so we're just going to call in a
manufacturing or other permitted use then it can have a certain amount of warehousing okay got it
and then I know as part of our conversation and also when I was talking with Ernie there's different
sub definitions of warehouses that many big companies are using now because of the negative
association with warehouses you know they're they're talking about fulfillment centers you know
some companies don't build warehouses they have fulfillment centers or data processing centers
because all these jobs formerly union jobs are being automated what are the sub definitions
that would be allowed within this this use are there Ernie I think I'd have to have specific
examples if it if it you know it's pretty obvious when you have a manufacturing use because you're
producing a product and it would have to meet that criteria if it was just kind of a
they're calling themselves some new name but it's a distribution warehouse you know if it walks
like a duck talks like a duck it's a duck okay so it would be evaluated on a case by case basis
it would go to the city discussion review process to make sure that it isn't trying to sneak in
something you know Armada you asked a good question the other day in our meeting which was
why is the district producing less truck trips when it's the film and center
and I probably should have you know the the traffic engine come up talk to that point but
it's a different kind of truck trip you have truck trips they go you know you know hundreds of
miles to unload at a warehouse like a fulfillment center then you have a business that has all
kinds of different size trucks that are coming back and forth all day long they're not traveling
to you know Michigan they're traveling across town and then coming back the same day so it still
counts as a truck trip even though it's not a semi so that's why the number is inflated for
industrial light industrial type uses that are businesses versus the distribution warehouse
it's a different kind of and if I could and we appreciate that that question because
we run into this issue quite a bit on the planning side and that is when you have businesses that
are going to come in and they present themselves as being one thing for instance light manufacturing
what we do is we work with them and ask for very specific descriptions of their processes of their
products to ensure that there isn't that they're not misrepresenting what exactly the process is
and it's not uncommon for us to reject uses because once we see what their processes are how
they're operating it becomes clear to us at times that wait this is logistics this is products
coming in being held for a certain amount of time and then leaving and we will it's not uncommon
for us to reject those and so as once these light industrial or business park facilities are
constructed that's when the work begins when there's actually a use that comes in they have
to demonstrate that they truly are using storage area in an appropriate way and that it's not
pure warehousing or logistics uses so I know that gets into the weeds a little bit but there
is a process to vet that no that makes sense I'm just I think what's what's behind what's at
the back of my head is that the 800 trucks right there's no warehouse but the the impact of of trucks
down rubiddle boulevard and market will be will be pretty consequential so that's 800 plus the other
500 trucks from the district so I'm just imagining 1300 trucks a day and I'm moving through those
streets right because the semi truck routes would be rubiddle boulevard and market boulevard
correct Jim those are those are the two on the eastern side they're two major ones yeah okay
okay great I have some questions about the land use the light industrial I know I received a few
emails just asking better understand land use do you have the city of Rupa Valley like the general
land use map that we might be able to look at I do let me pull that and so so the land use so light
industrial would go here where the real Vista is on this side and then just for folks to know light
industrial is all the pink the majority of the warehouses out here in Muraloma and even
some industrial areas are out in rubido they're all under the land use of light industrial
is there and I know that the Muraloma area that's under the warehouse overlay right so that's that's
a different dynamic but what would be some of the difference is that is that just the main the main
difference that we can't we what's built in real Vista we can't call it a warehouse
the main difference between Muraloma and no just just the the warehouses that are built in light
industrial land use all over Muraloma and rubido and built down and then this land use being
proposed for real Vista what what what are some of the biggest difference I know we had we expanded
the warehouse overlay into rubido last year but what's the what's the difference of it not being
within the overlay well it can't be a distribution warehouse use so it can't be a fulfillment center
okay but but it we we can still have think businesses okay you're just specific specific
business me a fulfillment center is just kind of like a midway point to get goods to the consumer
it's not really a business we're making something here or we're you know we're creating something
we're we're a company okay that's the biggest difference okay got it thank you that that's it
for for this one I just wanted to kind of get that that visual on on the I have a question on the
development agreement and maybe Brandon can help us with this one um and Joe so the development
agreement I was reading the contract it's between the city of group of valley and Canadian Pacific
land LLC a Florida based company and inland investors a Delaware where base company
it's stating that about 21.9 million dollars will be paid for by the project and a developer
I just want to get the numbers raised like it's about 21 almost 22 million is that correct is that
the total community benefits over the 20-year term yeah you're referring to yes
20 about 21.9 million okay but looking as I look closer on of it I saw that almost 20.76 million
dollars are actually paid for by CFDs which is a tax on residence so most of that community
probably what I don't know 98 percent of that development agreement that community benefit is
going to be paid for by residents is that correct I I have 19.7 million associated with the CFDs
19 million 19.7 million yes but that's that's in oh that's cumulative over 20 years right right okay
is it okay so I just wanted to to get get clear so when we're talking about the development agreement
really the that was negotiated with the developers they'll be responsible for the 1.8 million approximate
most of them are one-time fees right and then the 20 million or 19 million sorry will be paid
for by residents I just wanted to get that very clear yes so 20 about 19.7 will be associated with
the CFDs you're correct and then yeah about 2.8 I think it adds up to about 2.2 million over
the 20-year term those are the one-time impact fee not impact fees the one-time fees upfront okay
okay and then on the endowment there's 250 thousand dollars which is an endowment which really won't
be the entire money you know the whole money won't be used but it's going to be put in an account
where maybe what four percent will be able to use every year or how would the endowment work yeah I
think the vision for the endowment and and really when we're talking about an endowment in this
particular case it's more seed money because 250 thousand dollars clearly is not going to handle
the ongoing maintenance of this conservation area so everyone understands that it's an initial
infusion of revenue into that conservation area but the ongoing revenue that isn't stated within the
context of the development agreement are the ongoing HOA fees that will be providing a steady
and ongoing stream of revenue and perpetuity for that conservation area so the 250 thousand
dollars is a one-time infusion of revenue into it and then the HOA fees will cover the ongoing
aspect of that do we do we have an estimate of how much will be generated by the HOA and how
much will be put specifically towards the conservation of the open space and and the palm
rope I don't have those figures in front of me and that's something that could be directed
perhaps at the the applicant when they're at the podium okay we'll do and then I think that's good
Brandon I appreciate you thank you on the on the line industrial or sorry on the timeline of the
phases do we have a timeline for or an estimated amount of time when each phase will be completed
again I think that's something directed to the applicant got it and and question for us so one of
the as part of the presentation it said that the that the light industrial the non warehouse area
that that can't start until 170 units out of the 1600 units have been built it seems
that's what like 10 percent 10 percent of the housing units then they can start building
the the manufacturing facilities the big light industrial okay
great and then Jim you you had said and one of your the slides you talked about fire contributions
I believe that's the public safety CFD correct those are those one-time fees or is that
ongoing CFD so the 550 is an annual fee annual fee kind of okay last question
one or two more questions Joe you had mentioned that the project will bring will be generate
you mentioned revenue in in your your portion do we know how much revenue overall this project is
going to be generating on an annual basis or do we have estimates yet a little difficult to
determine that now because we're talking about things like property tax revenue that will change
over time depending on valuation of property we're talking about impact fees so there's there's a
lot of different elements that would need to go into calculating that we have not done that
what we were focusing in on is giving the council and at least an idea of what the
community benefits are within the DA but because those other factors are really unknown at this time
we have not come up with any estimates that I think would be necessarily useful at this time
okay thanks Joe and then my last question and kind of line was was around the roots so we're
seeing the cities in the city's pasture or assessment is that the roots are really no no longer than
30 feet is that a is that a guesstimate or is that an like an estimate or is there a clear like a
clear understanding of these roots I think the the issue there is based on our experts who have
gone out and looked at it they've determined first of all that in order to really I think know what
the root structure is there's really no way to determine that with certainty without potentially
damaging the roots themselves there's no non-invasive way really to do that and I are again
our experts are in the audience and they can elaborate on this perhaps more so what has been
used is the literature there's there's scientific literature that informed our you know kind of the
analysis and the the conclusion of this given the species and given what we know about those root
structures of this type of biological resource so that's really what was used as a determining
factor in estimating what the extent of the root structure itself do do we know the rock
structure I know there's you know that area has a number of of rocks and kind of different you know
different things do do we know kind of how how extensive that is or how how far deep it goes
and the radar study provides that information I'd suggest that maybe we have Mike Tuma come up
and talk about that because he's an expert on all of it sure sure so we did a ground penetrating
radar study at the site and indeed found that there's a bowl shaped depression beneath the oak
that's about three to six feet deep but oak roots could could fill that depression but also go into
cracks in the bedrock that sort of thing so the maximum depth would probably be around 30 feet
that's an estimate based on comparisons of other species related to this particular oak okay so
30 feet they've potentially broken through the the rocks unclear right but approximately 30 feet we
don't know where the rocks end at the bottom or how deep did we go in in the study so the ground
penetrating radar identified bedrock at three to six feet deep got it and nothing else there's
no way to visualize but if it penetrated through three feet of rock would penetrate it through
three to six feet of soil within that bowl to find the base of the rock right do we know how
thick the rocks are could be mild stick okay but we weren't just not sure we haven't looked at it
got it okay thanks no further questions at the moment you had a question right
I have a question about the parks and what the slide show said was that they have to build that
14 acre park by the 600th house and the pocket parks by what 75 so
I don't know what their absorption rate plan is but let's presume that they're really aggressive
and they can sell 100 units a year then you're talking about six years before a park comes in
that to me is unacceptable to the first 600 residents so I think that has to be adjusted they cannot
simply not have parks until the 600 unit it doesn't make sense so that's that's the only thing I'm
going to comment on at this moment thank you okay thank you very much so at this moment we're
gonna go ahead and open the public hearing and I will go ahead and just read off in the interest
of hearing everyone speakers are encouraged to not repeat what previous speakers have said and
only bring up new issues if possible please do not repeat the same position and raise the same
issues you can say I agree with the previous speakers we could encourage you to assign someone to speak
on your behalf if there's a group of citizens that hold the same position again this is only a
suggestion so for the interest of time do we have to hear everyone so we'll start with
10 minutes for the developer yes hello good evening mayor Silva members of the city council
Brian Hardy with Richland communities tonight we celebrate what we hope is the beginning of
a truly groundbreaking approach to development this approach is about far more than creating
spaces for people to live work and thrive it's about restoring harmony with the land's history
while transforming it into a community amenity as many of you know the site has fallen victim
to off-roading illegal dumping transient activity and trespassing but today we stand together on
the verge of a transformation that will turn this neglected area into an asset for the community
this transformation is made possible through a unique and powerful partnership with Kish
Nation whose deep-rooted connection to the land spans generations together we're embarking on a
journey to restore and develop this space addressing both its current challenges and its rich
historical significance and with that I'm going to turn it over to Jeremy with EPD thanks Brian
Jeremy crowd EPD solutions mayor council thank you for considering us want to thank the staff for
all the work to get to this point of course the planning commission for their marathon
hearings that occurred to get us to the council before you tonight and of course the community
for their interest in speaking and giving feedback I just quickly go through my slide deck
and I'll start with really the why the purpose of the SPA the reason we went here is we looked at
the context of the community the old the prior plan and looked at the industrialist to the east
and how that may not fit with the residential on the east side of the plan that's in the current
iteration of the plan and looking how that connection could really improve the situation
and allow for a lot more investment in the community and improvements on the site the current SPA
as you heard the specific plan which can be implemented you may hear differently from others
but there is an approved plan that can't be implemented and I'll speak to that in a minute but
we heard about the details but the critical thing in there is the protection of the yoke is not
assured in this plan in terms of the comparison there's a lot of detail here but I'll just highlight
the biggest ones with a specific plan that's approved on the left and the proposed plan on the
right you'll if the current plan is implemented you'd have fewer jobs smaller parks little diversity
in housing again on the proposed plan you'll have more jobs larger parks mix of housing types
because of the nature of the plan that's before you ensuring the protection of the yoke is not
guaranteed and not would not occur in the current plan but with the plan with it in partnership
with the Keats Nation there would be a plan in place for protecting the yoke and then as far as
schools the school site itself is there there are existing school sites in the existing plan
their subpar in this district would not accept them we increase the size of the school site in
the proposed plan the critical element in this is just to highlight a couple things as well beyond
just the numbers when you look at the existing plan there's very little buffer space between
the Crestridge and and San Diego communities on the west side or Sanislope communities I should
say on the west side and we really increase the open space from 405 acres to 510 acres in the
proposed plan so vast difference which allows for less grading much more open space and we heard
the comment earlier about the urban hedon and in fact the proposed plan would significantly
reduce that heat out in effect because there is more open space proposed of course the connection
to the freeways and and major roads is important and with the 20th street that you heard from mr peshis
in his presentation that connection of 20th is critical it connects a current island or space
in the city where there is no connection that's going to be made possible by the project
with major costs that can be funded beyond just the improvements that and the community benefits
that were you heard about earlier there's 29 million agreed and 22 million to construct the
20th 20th street improvements along the the center of the project essentially.
As you heard from Brian a moment ago this kind of noteworthy and very iconic agreement that has
been currently it's currently executed with memorandum of agreement with the tribe that covers a number
of topics including transfer of land in terms of the ability for them to maintain and control
the property for perpetuity and that's done through that will be done through the agreement
with the tribe biological and cultural monitoring importantly that's a thousand feet
of monitoring additional monitoring that the tribe will be involved in as construction occurs
and as we heard earlier the this formula the form of the agreement the details of the agreement
have to be in place with the tribe beyond just the current outline the memorandum of agreement
has to occur before any construction would occur on the site in the industrial areas.
So we have a protection in place and clear preservation plan that's required as part of
the agreement with the tribe it'll address things like the the palmer oak protection the fencing
access and how they would be on site to ensure that the success that the not just a palmer oak
but critically as you'll hear from the tribe the entire site the open space matters just as much
because they are looking at cultural and tribal resources on various areas of the site is not just
about the palmer oak and they're ensuring that success in the future.
And why the the Kitch nation they have been actively participating since 2018
they've responded to the city under AB 52 twice they've have a recorded sacred site
on the property they've provided the city with acknowledgement of their ancestral ties there's
active steps to safeguarding protecting this location they have longstanding history within
group of value in the area and they were present indisputably present in this area
of the long term and then other tribes have not been as the Tongva tribe has not been
responding in in the same manner so we really felt the connection with the tribe and seeing their
interests and the and the property and the protection in the long term.
As far as the expansion of buffer zone we talked about that earlier and it's really expanded from
the beginning to what you are seeing before you today those buffers have grown significantly
from as Jim said there's 80 feet in the existing plan but significantly grown since the original
plan based on studies going forward I have some slides after this one that I'll speak to in a moment
but I just want to make sure mention that the history of the biological analysis from 2006 all
the way to 24 and what we have found is that the original studies were only looking at oak tree
management protection requirements under the Riverside County guidelines which only required
drip line protection have expanded significantly obviously since what was studied back in 2006
to what we're proposing today of 450 feet and then as far as sorry just on the last I have some
slides here where there's missing images because the confidential nature the council has a packet
that has the confidential slides but or photos this one is really just to identify the studies and
the effort that has taken place as we heard earlier to understand and protect the the Palmer Oak
and what's critical is status quo does not work the status quo of continuing what's out there today
what's allowed on the site would not ensure the protection we've seen trespassing damage graffiti
and other things occurring around the Palmer Oak and around the site you know about the off-roading
and again it's not just about the Palmer Oak it's the entire site that has resources and those
are being are threatened despite a lot of security presence on the site again a number of slides
that the council has to just show the buffering that is presented on slides 14 15 and 16
with the recognition of the slope and the location of the Palmer Oak high up on a hill
and then relative to that there is development that would be far away and below the hill so
again we heard some about questions I heard questions from the council about the roots
the important thing is the roots would be going through the the hill that is entirely preserved
under this plan so the hill that where potentially if if for some reason there were roots in a different
location or meaning lower than what's been analyzed the entire hill is preserved but what we have found
is that through the studies that experts have conducted the roots would not go as far down as
some have said in some of the comments you may hear tonight as well
so the last on this piece there are a couple of slides again just about where illegal dumping
is occurring at the base of that hill that's one thing that we'd work with a tribe to ensure
the cleanup of that area as well and then finally again that this slide just represents the that
hill that is a significant elevation difference of over 190 feet between where the Palmer Oak is and
where any development could occur the plan itself again is important to recognize in the protection
that will occur as part of the project of the Oak and that is identified in this slide just to
what is occurring under the proposed project and the approval and the coordination with a tribe
and then another buffer exhibit just to show the the growth of the the buffer over time which
is critical to recognize and then finally just a couple slides on the existing versus the proposed
specific plan the existing plan can be implemented there's track maps that were prepared and can
be submitted but again we have a better plan and a better approach to moving forward
and then I have the slides on I'll just skip through to the very end which I think is important
to recognize which is a couple things the the business park area would highlight some I lost
slides some business park areas that have some really good spaces for businesses that are community
oriented and have something similar to what you have in the city today the Brook Hall business
park with smaller businesses as you heard before lastly the richland communities in and out
Chino facility is an example of the light industrial facility that has very high
nice residential near it and could be a place for the city for the time thank you thank you
I have a few questions or sorry man you have something I have just some questions
do you have to do yeah I could do after or go ahead just some questions um thanks Jeremy you you had
mentioned in previous meetings you had mentioned that the that the initial specific plan that it was
not financially feasible for you guys to to make that possible but recently you've talked about the
the need to have a new specific plan is is to protect the oak right I just want to get a sense
what what is what is priority to to you um so I believe I understand your question
and they may be somewhat related but there might be a little bit of difference there
one thing just on the the financial feasibility of the existing plan the reason it hasn't been
built to date has been financially related there has been challenges with the cost of building
all the infrastructure on site the grading that's required schools and other improvements
so that has been a challenge date we have seen a change in the market though residential pricing
as you know is still remains high and there is a high interest in the housing that's needed the
the housing shortage has continued to be a problem throughout the state we know that the state has
adopted the house has recognized a housing crisis throughout the state that has has been uh
implement already seen that occur because pricing is is risen so at this time the actually the
existing plan has financial feasibility yes it may take longer to build out because there's
a singular or a very similar product throughout the project but it's still financially feasible
it's just the the timing to build out may be longer under the existing plan but the important
thing under that plan is there is no protection under that plan there is no agreement for that
there is no that buffer itself as I mentioned it is significantly less the planning area that's
closest to the bomber oak in that plan is about 80 feet so there is a very limited
protection in that plan so the proposed plan holds that back we've worked with staff and the
experts to identify the minimum and then we went significantly beyond that to ensure that
protection and the reason that can occur is that it has the funding to allow for the infrastructure
that's needed and then space to dedicate for open space around the bomber oak and the last thing
I'll just point out is that when you look at a plan that has housing all up against the bomber
oak that means you have a much more porous boundary up against the bomber oak where the
residents who live up against the bomber oak you can't control that very well under the proposed
plan which is like dust roll you have one tenant that's going to be next to it and it's a controlled
space you would have workers that come in and out in the morning and then leave at night residents
you have there 24 hours a day that could decide that they want to access the bomber oak and so
it's harder to control that boundary so there's a number of factors that went in there to lead to
the plans that's before you so why not why not make modifications to this plan why why add the
the industrial portion so you're you're saying it's like what what's the reason that you're bringing
to add the warehouse there or the industrial area right and all the semi trucks is that
because to me that seems like it's pure financial motive right because they'll there'll be more
money coming in you'll be able to complete the project make more money off the end at the end of
the day right well first yeah no warehouse I heard you mentioned warehouse so there's no warehouse
proposed the industrial the industrial area where they had hundred semi trucks yeah and just to make
the 800 is actually not 800 trucks it's those are trips so that's one way out one way back
okay that's a that's it could be 400 actually and I'll point out just on that last one that our
concept plan for the site is actually significantly less so on this slide you'll see so what's what we're
proposing in the specific plan is about one million two hundred sixty nine square feet
two hundred sixty nine thousand square feet of a light industrial the proposed or the concept
plan for the site which is what you see here again this has not been submitted to the city and
we've done it for planning purposes only to understand what the potential square footages
because of grading and because of buffering it was down at eight hundred eight thousand so it reduced
it by a significant amount and then with the plan because of the additional buffering on the
pomeroke is reduced even further to seven hundred thousand so we have some significant reductions
from what's in the what was analyzed but nevertheless the numbers that you said are the trips associated
with it and the reason we have the different use here in this area really goes back to it's not
there is a financial component to allow for the building of 20th in a timely manner so this this
type of use allows building 20th as quickly as possible because funding can come in sooner from
a tenant who may be interested in this area who can lease from the buildings by building and they
can allow for the building of the road also there's a planning side of it when we looked at this and
worked with staff again many years ago 2018 or so we looked at the industrial to the east and we
said what is appropriate for adjacencies to those uses and what was what we found in talking to
staff and looking at the plan was a plan like this instead so planning purposes also was a primary
driver to the planning seat today because there's already industrial so it might as well add a little
reason immediately adjacent to the this area so in in that picture just to that bottom corner
but doesn't it you know it doesn't you know just the juxtaposition of having literally the oldest
living being or the third type third living oldest living being in the planet the oldest tree or shrub
or or space in the in the state of california and and and the proposal is to build an industrial
facility a manufacturing facility a few hundred feet away that it that juxtaposition it just
strikes me as it is just so disturbing right because it's the it's the semi trucks oh it's the semi
truck trips right 800 coming in and out it's it and it's just the the message that it's sending
right to to our community that really it you know there are some additional buffers i get that
um but just that juxtaposition just sends me it's really like it's it seems like a slap on the face
to to our rubido and and kind of that that community i don't know how what do you have to say about
that but i i understand your position and i'd say that the a couple things one is they're not the
trucks that you mentioned these are smaller trucks as well so you're you're bringing everything
and calling them semi trucks that's not at all what's what's being proposed but that hasn't that hasn't
have you uh so like this is an example for as you let us know what type what types of
trucks are going to be exactly so uh for example some of these uses that you see here so this is a
similar business park that we modeled after some of the plans that you see on the site plan when we
took staff with us to to show the example this is las betronis and it has a golf cart facility as a
brewery it has other facilities and so that again these are businesses they have plumbing
contractors they have others that where they do have maybe a box truck and they have other trucks
that are associated with the business and those are the ones that it could be two axle could be
three axle but the important thing is that there are these sometimes drive the trips up because
as we heard from mr peshis earlier that they are serving a local community so i would say that
these are actually serving the community more than the ones that you were associating us with
mirror lobe and other areas these are serving the community so so you're saying it's it's not
going to be semi trucks it's going to be golf carts 800 golf carts a day uh well that would be
a lot of golf carts but the uh as far you know what i was saying that's what you're making
it seem you show a picture of golf carts oh no yeah so that's the business and they have to get
parts for the golf carts in order for those to work so they they would have trucks to deliver those
to the site uh to build their golf carts right right but so it's not golf carts it's
larger trucks right but but you don't do you don't know exactly which trucks are going to
uh are going to be driving through there at the at this point so the the traffic analysis was done
looking at the worst case scenario so it could be much less because the the worst case scenario
was critical for analyzing how many what are the road improvements the signal improvements
and other improvements that are needed to serve a project like this yeah no i i read the traffic
you sorry you're interrupting Jeremy you as the applicant and kind of directing this project
do you know um what type of building you're going to build what type of trucks are you're
going to have at this point it will be similar to what's analyzed in the traffic study or much less
and so i think that's the critical thing that we've analyzed the worst case to allow for
a full understanding of the traffic improvements uh so that the traffic will continue to flow with
build out of this project right so um and and you know and again it's just and you you talked
about truck trips i i i wanted you to to uh share with us just uh what's the message you're trying to
send by by building an industrial facility with 800 truck trips 814 truck trips a day um uh 400
feet away or 100 yards 100 meters from um the world's oldest the third oldest organism in this
planet and the oldest tree in california what's the message that you're trying to send to to our
community well because the studies that have been done the analysis that was prepared and then
the additional buffer that's actually 550 feet to the nearest building with that we are saying we
care about so that the when we started with the project we said the the pomor oak is important to
us it's important to the community we understood the the importance of it from a historical sense
even pre-historical sense it's very historic and so that was baked into the plan we looked at that
and said what do we do to protect the tree uh the the pomor oak and we designed the plan around
that and we also over time as we involved the the kitchenation we understood there is more than
just the pomor oak here there is a lot of resource on the site that we have to protect so in order
to do that we said let's involve the tribe let's have them be a critical party in this in this
effort so that we protect not just the pomor oak but also the the resources that are throughout the site
this project because of what we're proposing can fund that can can bear that and allow for a long
term preservation of of important resources in the area and and I appreciate the the consultation
I think that's critical and that's vital for for our community especially for how much land
this country's stolen from Native Americans but I'm wondering were they part of the designing of
this project or did you just bring them in for the conservation aspect would they help you design
the industrial areas and everything well they have been on the site with us on a regular basis we
invited them they did multiple site visits to to look at the the entire property from end to end
north to southeast west and looked at where are these potential resources they they worked with us
as we were designed the plan to ensure that we avoided or ensure we recognize where the resources
were and that did impact the plan and it did impact how we would move forward and are they
so I know they're going to get some of some of the land but are they part of are they equity
partners in the actual the profitable aspect of the project or they just just having they're just
in charge of the conservation so the tribe would be in charge of the their mission is to it and they
may want to speak to this more specifically than I they are looking for an area to preserve their
heritage to recognize what they feel is valuable on the site and they are very vested in that effort
this project will help fund that and they are very vested in ensuring that would occur that's why
we've worked with them for so long okay and then I know you you you've partnered with labor here
for this project is that only for construction of the industrial areas and the homes is or is that
also for the retail and the companies that are coming going to come in so that you have the
labor that you see here and that you've probably heard from they are they are involved in the
construction element they are very involved in all efforts so that's not just the the homes but
there's parks there's school there's other efforts there's a school itself and there's
probably a specific union relative to the teachers that are going to be on site but so all the
construction is going to be done with union labor correct correct yeah so they are involved
in the project site and then what about the the companies that end up becoming tenants
and the other shops are are they going to be unionized they we don't have tenants before so
we don't know what they if they have labor what their plan is so at this age if we build a building
meaning we being richland owners if they build a building they would have the labor union
being very involved in that and then as the tenants occupied the tenants may not have
many improvements to do on the inside of we're not sure and so but you'd be okay with with let's
just say a tenant that doesn't use unionized labor that doesn't support labor unions
would I be okay that it's up to the the business come in but I I can't control them but I would
strongly encourage them and I think they would see the the value and the the quality of construction
that the union would would be involved in the site and you'd see what they've been able to
complete on the property and I'd expect that they'd be interested in union labor okay and
Jeremy last question do you know and I'm sure you've done the economic assessment of the project
what's the ROI that you're expecting on this overall project so I'm not I don't get involved in the
financial side relative to that but I think the important thing is that the investment that's
occurred since the beginning the richland communities bought the property as an entitled
allowed to be built site so again the site has a residential specific plan on the site is
allowed for residential so there is a significant value with that so they paid a number of funds for
that that was back in I believe 2011 or so I got involved in 2014 embarrassingly my kids were
very young I had two and not three like I do now and since then there's been a number of plans
that have come forward before since then the market has changed significantly so there has been
and during that whole time funding for the process that your staff the studies that have
occurred have been very significant so I expect that they're your return but also
importantly the community investment that's going into the the city
but but you don't have a sense of what the what the ROI how much money is going to be made through
the whole project you know hundred two hundred million dollars going to go in permits and
administrative costs is a billion dollars two billion over the next 20 years hundred years
yeah I don't know I think yeah so these are the the community benefits and the
significance of the improvements so we have two hundred million yes you're right about the
amount of investment in the community and this is just fees and community benefits alone there's
just the construction costs that I mentioned before of millions and dollars that's separate from this
so we have significant amount of improvements or funds that are going into the city
for various areas and then I think I did hear a question that you have you asked about the
about revenue coming into the city you did ask about that and that was this slide shows about three
million dollars of city tax revenues that were estimated and was considered as part of the development
agreement process and so that lists all the various taxes that would come on an annual basis going
to the city that's paid for by residents and and the businesses right so these there's property
tax motor vehicle and you can yeah the fees are there so a lot of the costs and are from the people
that'll be on the site but that is not insignificant and it will be through funding of this project
it allows this to occur okay thanks for me okay thank you very much now we'll bring up the first
speaker Tony Sanchez or Tony Tony Sanchez we have one that just say Stephanie is there Stephanie
there's no last name on here sorry thank you so I'm here today because I'm concerned about some of
the ecological effects that this development would have I'm I am concerned about the heat island
effect how this would impact the oak as well as the surrounding ecosystem previously I quoted
Matthew Tatimas about this is the oh I'm sorry thank you I'm here today because I'm concerned
about the heat island effect and how this would impact the oak and the the natural ecosystem surrounding
it and I'm going to be drawing from a previous comment from Dr. Krantz about the heat island
effect specifically and the lack of scientific rigor that has been applied or not applied
to the studies claiming that this would be safe the consultants L&L environmental took
temperature readings early in the morning on July 4th between the hours of 7 30 a.m. and 9 a.m.
during time when it is cooler and they they concluded from these three measurements on this
one day that they made conclusions about the the safety of the the temperature and why the heat
island effect would have it would not it would have no effect on the oak but temperatures taken
from a single day within three hours is not this does not have scientific validity two days later
Dr. Krantz went out with a thermometer at the base of the outcrops at 2 30 in the afternoon when real
peak temperatures are achieved and documented an ambient air temperature of 103.7 degrees near
the tree whereas at that same time asphalt temperatures on the adjacent street near the tree were 151
degrees so that's a difference 103 degrees 151 degrees on asphalt and I'm quoting Dr. Krantz here
if you multiply that times 2.7 million square feet of rooftops and asphalt immediately adjacent
to the tree and you've got a real quantifiable urban heat island impact for the consultant to
consider this as insignificant I think is shameful and I just wanted to say that that they give some
material there on the the lack of scientific rigor that has been applied here I would I would
ask that the the Rio Vista plan as it is is not approved as it is because the developers should
be required to do their due diligence their developer should do better I believe there should
be indigenous stewardship of the land conservation and protection of the land without it being
contingent or coming with the condition of of development which will existentially threaten
the oak and the surrounding and ecosystem thank you so much I wish I knew I had that comment thank you
our next speaker is Robin Merwin do we have a Rob Robin Merwin okay next speaker it just says
Mike R oh wait hold on this one says on top don't need him to Tim Krantz okay we'll go to Ashley
Gallardo and then just to have the next speaker ready Tyler R I'm speaking as someone who has grown
up in the IE and was born in the IE and I've seen how development has destroyed natural habitats
and that is something I don't want to see happen to this spot I've spoken to some of the indigenous
groups and I'm worried that whatever happens it's going to happen and that we speak whether or not
we have anything important to say it's it's already done so I'm just here to hopefully
really emphasize how important this spot is based off of the fact that is one of the oldest trees in
the world I don't I don't think that should be undermined in any way we should look at the world
and focus on the fact that this is one of the oldest trees dating back to the ice age and the
fact that the whole environment there has some endangered species that should be protected not
built over with housing that will probably not be able to be afforded by the people who live here
a lot of these people probably won't be living in these houses I live somewhere where I've seen
development take over and housing being prioritized for people outside of the city and I do not want
to see that in this case so as nice as it seems all these parks all these spaces I'm hoping they're
not empty promises to wipe people out and to wipe the indigenous people as well as the habitat out
I'm just hoping that the people in their suits keep that in mind because it's more than just suits
and it's more than just you know having these meanings it's about the actual impact is going
on the one the world it was 120 today 120 I don't know if you experience that within an air
conditioned space but that's really hot and it's only going to get hotter and as somebody who is a
youth and has witnessed the damage that in development and this uncaring way about the earth has led
to so much damage I've seen it with my eyes I'm sure you guys are piecing it to whether you
want to see it or not but these are actual impacts that we have to really take into account and not
just allow to pass for money because I know that that's what the main backing for this is
and I don't know if anything I can say can change that but I'm just hoping that we really take into
account the indigenous as well as the environment we just need to really focus on that and not just
focus on the money and that is what I really want to emphasize and that whatever happens I just
really want the nature to be preserved as much as possible and that is what I'm advocating for
so I'm hoping you guys take that into account and take the voices of others who also want that as well
whether this occurs or not I'm just hoping the land is protected this indigenous species
because whether homes are built there they're going to continue to exist they're going to see
people they're going to see animals in their backyards and I don't want to see those animals
wiped out for the people there who are probably transplants people who can afford it while the
people who are actually in this room cannot so just please stick that into account I don't know if
this is going to stick with you guys if any of this is actually going to get through to you but
I'm hoping it's both deeper than your pockets and the people here can get to live within their
environment because it is so important that the indigenous people have access to their own land
very Palestine free riverside from 30 people and I'm hoping they can get what they want out of this
thank you next speaker Tyler R okay so we have a robin bona but she's donating time to Jenny Eider
Eider
mayor council members Jenny Eider lifelong resident of our harupa valley thank you for
everything that you guys do for our city honestly thank you I love harupa valley I'm sure you all do
too and I don't want to see us make the mistake of endangering the life of the oldest living oak
on the planet by approving the Rio Vista plan as it was presented to you tonight
let us not trade the life of the third oldest known living plant on the planet for two and a half
million square feet of monday industrial and business park buildings your studies do not show
where the harunga oaks ancient roots are located nor all the places where the oak could be getting
its water your studies do not thoroughly explore how the urban heat island effect could harm the oak
nor how diesels that could harm the oak you did not study how invasive species and pathogens
could harm the oak nor how a warming climate will affect the oak we could know all these things
before we make the decision on the size of a buffer around the oldest known oak on the planet
visionary elected officials would kill for the place making opportunity the harunga oak provides
us we are a new city with an old soul let's celebrate something uniquely us that we can be
proud of there are multiple Native American tribes who call the project area sacred and want to be
heard why are we only working with the one and excluding the others let's get a grant by the land
put a fence around the oak and then invite residents scientists and all the first peoples
of our home to weigh in on how to protect and celebrate this treasure public scoping meetings
are a hallmark of good planning for projects with way less on the line last year's environmental
justice meeting held two days before Thanksgiving was a start but next time you could do a better
job inviting the public and choosing a more accessible date and that was at that meeting
uh play this right and harupa valley could have a UNESCO world heritage site state park
and our own unique emblem of strength and resiliency play it wrong and we have kindling
and sell storage facilities which are an approved use in this plan pause this project so we can
come up with a smarter protection plan or error on the site of caution with a 100 acre preserve
that protects the source of groundwater under the oak do not squander the opportunity the
haranga oak provides harupa valley will not get another one like it thank you
harbor ire and after that is forest pick um mayor council members and a long time member resident
of harupa valley and i have some concerns first one was the way that you are characterizing the
empty land now as i look over from the top of 20th street just beyond uh the new park there
and i look out over this land and i do see some dumping and i do see some graffiti
but i also see in the spring you know wet spring the whole hills covered in yellow
and sea and so flowers and then the and then the sunflowers come and the gold benches come to eat
the in flocks and the house benches come and over all the red deals hawks here five maybe looking
for the rabbits whose tracks i see in the dirt or a sneak or and all these critters are going to
be squeezed down more than half their land is going to be taken and all you're going to have to
left are the really steep ones that are really too steep for horseback riders or or hikers that i
see out there now they're too steep the remaining ones unless somebody makes a really good path
the second thing is now the training center has been moved off of this area how about putting
industrial there if you put some of the industrial there then maybe you can push back and make a
bigger one acre section around the oak just a thought also i think we should consider that the
the water scarcity uh right now we have enough water all of us have enough water in our homes
in our buildings but the california state water resources control board has made new regulations
to conserve water supplies the regulations require water suppliers such as rubiddle
community services district and harupa community services district to reduce the amount of water
they provide to customers over the next 15 years or be fined as much as 10,000 a day
locally rubiddle community services district would be required to reduce our water by 20 to 30
percent over the next 15 years less water in about 15 years real this don't come online and then
there will be more users and less water thank you horseback and then next up is Zach's
strawster good evening thank you for listening my name is forceback and i'm representative on
behalf of uh local 364 pipe fidders and plumbers um local 364 proudly supports this project
and of the applicants commitment to hiring local skilled and training workforce union
members we ask for your support with this yes votes tonight on this project many of our members live
within this very community and are proud to be helping to develop the various aspects that make
up this project including the tree and i think this is a very cool project to build around this tree
and live around this tree and basically build a protective area around this tree that we can we
can live around and be right there in the uh in the wild enjoying it and uh right now it didn't seem
like we're protecting it but it's uh getting depleted and this project will help that out
we'll be helping to develop and grow the city of rupa valley and lay the foundation for many
generations to come that my daughter can enjoy and her kids can enjoy a very good community that
i'm excited to help build please help support us by voting yes on this project thank you thank you
the extra uh thrusters and after that would be godless eskella all right so first of all good
evening my name is xx thrusters and i'm here on behalf of care california we're a coalition and
organization that represents tens of thousands of people community members uh from various sectors
we represent um so many people from so many groups so when we come out to hearings first and foremost
we do not come to protect developers we do not come to toe the line simply because a project
is being developed if you ask them we're ruthless when it comes to community standards so when we come
before this dias when we come before this body we don't come as yes men we don't come to see you rubber
stamp project we come i come personally to make sure that it meets and exceeds the expectations
of the city granted you're going to have groups no matter what no matter where that don't agree
with any form of development and granted you may have some substantial arguments as to why you
don't believe that this is a good fit for the area but let me tell you there are a few reasons that
are absolutely outstanding that you cannot argue two hundred million dollars in cumulative
community benefits over the course of 20 years that would not otherwise come to this city if
it wasn't for private development now the only reason that's not appealing to you is if you don't
care about community benefits and if you want to know the truth about what i've seen based on my
experience and i've gone to many hundreds of hearings in many cities let me tell you that this
developer over the course of more than 10 years just based just based on the applicant's presentation
that they have gone through the ringer time and time again i'm amazed that they want to
still continue to build in harupa i'm amazed that they still want to continue with this project
because they could have sold this land but instead they didn't and they moved forward
and you have city staff that has spent countless hundreds of hours that has gone through the
absolute most quintessential details of this project and the community opposition might be
high for certain groups but let me tell you they are a vocal minority how do i know that
the quiche nation is a representation of the indigenous peoples that believe in this project
one two and i'm going to bring it right home you got 1700 housing units that would not otherwise
be built and it has to do with private development it has to do with the business park it has to do
with what draws people in because if you don't have jobs you don't build houses and i'm here
to tell you that your arena numbers do not lie they get presented to us by the state the attorney
general looks at these numbers and says this is what's reasonable you have not only the state
but the nation looking at what areas that are otherwise relatively rural need to do in order
to meet the human factor and more than anything harupa is a community of communities and those
communities are based on people people and those people need houses approve this project thank you
god bless us karlos esqueda after that would be israel corrales good evening honorable mayor and
city councilors my name is karlos esqueda and i'm here to speak enthusiastically in favor of item
15b the Rio Vista project this project has the support of the quiche nation local commercial
interest various labor organizations the local community city staff and has already been approved
by the planning commission who thoroughly investigate question this project leaving no stone on turn
and no question without ask therefore please support the public welfare private industry and
community of indigenous and otherwise both to approve this project tonight thank you and god bless
you
israel corrales after that is alicia i think it's drive down uh good evening
number of mayor and uh city council my name is israel corrales and i'm here tonight speaking
favor of the real vista project this project represents downses and jobs and hundreds of
millions of dollars for our city harupa valley um for this i just want to leave you to support
my generation and our future with your yes vote tonight on this project thank you and god bless
is alicia here yeah okay after that uh jonathan daily hi um hello council members my name is alicia
drive doll and i'm here to speak in strong opposition to the rio vista project um as many have mentioned
this issue concerns um not only the oak but the entire landscape the entire ecosystem which is home
to many species rare and endangered whose habitat is threatened by this development to quote the
friends of harupa of the harup oak um in order for this development to proceed um the sage scrub
dominated hills where will first be blown up with explosives and graded flat for building
construction removing hundreds of acres of habitat occupied by the endangered california
nat catcher this is in clear conflict with the city of harupa valley's general plan
which specifically identifies policies for conserving sage scrub habitat occupied by the nat catcher
any developments approved by the city ought to be in line with the city's general plan
and clearly this land used is um is inconsistent with the policies and goals of the city's general
plan um this is policy um cos 1.1 habitat conservation um which states the city ought to conserve large
intact um habitat areas consisting of coastal sage scrub shoproll and grasslands to support
known locations of the coastal california nat catcher and quote and um new quote conserved
grassland adjacent to sage scrub for foraging habitat for raptors um for this reason and more
i'm in strong opposition to the real vista project um and i trust you to make the right
decision thank you for your time jonathan daily after that is one serato good evening my name is
jonathan daily i'm a marine core veteran i'm proud member of layuna labors union
um a lot of us are here tonight um we're here in support of this project
we're here on behalf of a lot of a lot of members a lot of families um me me myself i'm a husband
i'm a father to a one-year-old um so these these projects and developers like this is is what
allows me to provide my family with health care um a livable wage roof over our heads um that goes
for everybody standing behind me um what i like about this project is is one uh we're grateful
enough to be a part of it um and two i you know the school the housing the parks i mean me being
a family guy i like to you know visualize myself and communities and and kind of see where i fit
in and i've been here um a while now and um would definitely like to see myself be able to buy a house
pretty soon um i'm fortunate enough to allow my wife to be a stay-at-home mom uh it's really hard
to do in california but because of the union because of these projects um i'm grateful to be
able to do that um so with that said we're in support of this project and we hope you are too
thank you thank you one after that is evan web uh hello good evening uh steam members of the
council uh i want serato representing the labors international union north america uh we la una
staff for excellent instruction prioritizing safety and skilled labor the real vista specific
plan in haruba valley is crucial for our community uh this project addresses our housing
shortages providing more options for residents it also includes beautiful parks
green spaces enhancing our quality of life economically uh this project will create quality
jobs to support local businesses loosen our local economy or reduce commute times for workers
improving their lives and reducing traffic congestion our hiring union labor we ensure
high quality safe construction benefiting the entire community uh supporting the real vista
specific uh plan is an investment in the future of haruba valley promoting sustainable growth and
development um so thank you after your time consideration thank you
evan web no okay we're gonna go to louis lopez oh wait are you evan web okay hold on louis lopez
you're next okay hi um i'm evan web just want to speak in opposition against this project
so first off uh i don't live in rupa valley i'm right up the street in fontana and in my 21 years
of life uh i just want to say that with this project it's going to be very ecologically destructive
particularly with the light industrial um as a fontana resident i've seen how the city has
expanded um you know the presence of light industrial in the city destroying homes and
destroying very delicate ecosystems to the point where there's hardly any natural green space in
uh city proper the fontana and i highly encourage um group of valley to you know
you know decline this project to protect the oak and the beautiful and delicate ecosystems
around the oak so yeah in other words uh don't go down the path that fontana has been going
down for 20 years and yeah that's it thank you really open and after that is sharon robert
Good evening mayor council members staff community my name's louis lopez i'm a business
agent for the iron workers local 433 and i'm here tonight uh representing over 5600 members
um this project here is actually a model project uh all the investment resources all the studies
all the time that's been put in this project and i can tell you um i've gone to many of these
and this project here just in its magnitude uh just uh by far exceeds other projects in the region
um this this is a model project here and um with all the other trades behind us uh we take honor
and uh and being invited to this project to be able to build um i'm also a marine core veteran
got two tours um the good thing about all our trades back here is that we have a four
five year apprenticeship depending on what's trade and uh our veterans um have a high very high
success rate um go through the four year apprenticeship they have a fast track through helmets to
hard hats so those men and women coming from serving our country looking for a good affordable or good
high paying job with benefits that's a retirement that's a 401k um and it's just shy of college
credits from getting an actual degree um so when we're invited to these projects it's really
a heartbeat it's a lifeline uh for our survival for our future and just uh helping those men and
women uh like i said uh have a heart for veterans many of our veterans that complete the apprenticeship
program ultimately succeed in leadership roles uh as far as the housing um we do uh my members
get up three four o'clock in the morning go to work every day so these new housing projects
i can guarantee you that some of the families back here will be looking to purchase homes
act there because we have a good paying job we go to work every day we have benefits so
with that be saying um you know i'm in support my members aren't in support of this this project
and uh i'd just like to thank the developer for including this in this in this development
and look forward to uh producing a high quality product at the end thank you god bless
thank you for that Sharon Roberts up next and after that Tim Krenz
hello i am a resident here for 40 years i recognize some of your faces i go to some of your businesses
i am for this project i am for jobs i am for unions i am for houses i am for the oak i am for
environmentalists there has to be a meeting point and when i hear that the rigor of the studies just
wasn't there i'm not even a scientist and i know going out one day getting temperatures
one time at seven thirty in the morning is not rigor as another person said let's
pause and get the rigor so we can all be happy and the oak can survive and the houses can be
built thank you Tim Krenz and after that is Jose Radillo so it's gonna be two six minutes okay
yeah thank you mr mayor honorable members of the council my name is Dr. Tim Krenz
and i'm i'm speaking on behalf of a broad coalition of environmental groups
technical experts environmental justice organizations and Native American tribes
we're concerned about the rio vista project and it's the very minimal setbacks that are
established proposed to be established around the harupa oak the oldest living oak tree on earth
I'm not opposed to the rio vista specific plan development at all and neither are my colleagues
we are only concerned about the plan areas immediately uphill and adjacent to the oak tree
plan areas involved are the two light industrial plan areas 12 and 13 and the wet and the southern
half of the business park plan area 15 even here our concern is only about the setback from the oak
one can do this project and create all the jobs and still maintain this iconic tree
this should be on your city emblem the the our concern again is really focused on those light
industrial areas 1.3 million square feet of light industrial development immediately uphill
from the oak itself if you refer to the figure that i've gotten you're the back of my hand out
here the top figure you can see that the oak itself at the center of those circles
is immediately downhill all of the watershed and the the water capture from the drainage divide
to the west extends down towards that oak tree this is the groundwater that has supported that tree
for thousands of years if you look at the other figure you can see that the watershed map again
all of those blue lines coming down towards the oak tree itself now if we go back to the
scientific quote unquote scientific studies that have been done by the consultants
you'll see that in fact the root analysis done by first carbon solutions is very hypothetical
they begin their analysis with there is no non-invasive technique that can effectively
map the root system of this species there's no way to know that and so they estimate then that
the depth of those roots based on typical scrub oaks as extending to 30 feet this is no typical
scrub oaks it's been existing there for 13 to 18 000 years if it grew only an inch a year
which would be very slow for a typical oak it would be over a couple hundred feet deep
down to groundwater that has sustained it through droughts and wildfires and other adverse
conditions over the centuries so and then you've heard from the urban heat island effect the
consultants who knowingly said that they've worked with the developer not with the city but
with the developer since 2013 doing their their heat temperature readings at 730 in the morning
that same day the temperatures got over 104 with temperatures on the asphalt right next to the
tree at 150 degrees you multiply that times 2.7 million square feet of rooftops and pavement
and you've got a real quantifiable problem so what we're asking here is not the disapproval
of this project we're only asking that you allow us all to get together and really see this information
concerning the environmental impacts potential environmental impacts to the oak most of that
information has been redacted and withheld from the general public because of its cultural
sensitivity we all agree that this is indeed a sacred being this oak tree the haruna oak it names
this city harupa is derived from that very name we're only asking that you continue this hearing
to a later date to be determined establish an independent select committee of Native American
representatives oak experts environmental scientists and others to independently look at all of the
data all of the information and make recommendations back to you so that we can make real viable proposals
for the conservation of this important tree finally i'd like to reemphasize we're not opposed to the
real VISTA specific plan development as a whole we are only concerned with the impacts of the
plan areas immediately above and adjacent to the tree we ask that you give us the opportunity
to sit down together and work out a compromise that allows development to go forward and also
provides real and permanent protections for this ancient organism the harupa oak the haruna oak
indeed the harupa oak is an emblem of endurance and perseverance since the ice age and during
droughts and fires and climate change and yet persisting on its rocky crags overlooking the
harupa valley thank you for the opportunity to provide these comments to this relative to this
most unique and precious resource that is the harupa oak thank you.
Mr. Odeo and then after that Danny Renee. Good evening mayor and council thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Jose Redillo i'm a proud member of La Una labor international
union of north america and we support this project moving forward and first of all I would like
to thank the developer for their own way of support their reliability and excellent work
through this collaboration of this project. La Una has been building the America for over a
century we want to continue to build that continue to build America and our dedicated members are
eagerly awaiting the opportunity to initiate to this remarkable project such projects are vital
to our financial our vital tools to us to enables us to meet to
able us to meet our financial obligation and also provide for our loved ones
together lists in power our community foster inclusivity and drive progress together for a
more equitable and prosperous society let us unite and build a future bringing with
possibility i invite you all to support this project as it takes us one step closer to building
a brighter future i invite you to support this project also thank you for your time.
Danny Renee up and then after that i think it's Tholia Davila hello i am here to speak an
opposition of the Rio Vista project the plan is flawed it does not include a sufficient environmental
impact report the effect of paving over an existing ecosystem is absolutely going to impact the
ancient oak in detrimental and unknown ways among many other precious and necessary species
if the plan is approved as is there is nowhere for the rainwater to go if the plan is approved as
is the roots of the ancient oak will not receive the water it needs and has needed to live for
over 13,000 years the development plan as is will kill the oak there isn't enough of a buffer there
isn't a buffer large enough that could protect the vast root system of the ancient oak and the
many species it supports please honor the land that continues to be there for us and do not
approve the Rio Vista plan i also want to add that the the alternate option that is presented
from the 90s is false that is not a true alternate option thank you please do not approve this plan
we have Tholia after that is Mack Maxwell all righty good evening mayor council members citizens
and developers i call to appeal to your humanity let's be real here the heatwave this week is very
ominous is a very ominous sign of how much we have already taken from this earth in the name of
lining the pockets of the few we've seen projects like this before we see them all over the city
and the state and we know the truth that these projects harm more than help the local community
and ecosystems we know that this project will mostly line the pockets of a small few at Richmond
communities take a look around you how much the people in the environment are struggling
what good are these new jobs when they don't pay pay enough to live off of i personally know many
union members who work full time and still have to live out of their cars um
and we have heard these vague phrases and empty promises before it breaks my heart to see the
quiche nation offered so little richland communities should feel ashamed of these scraps they have
offered the first nations of this land we can't afford to take baby steps anymore we don't accept
your scraps anymore there's no housing crisis we have enough homes already built for everyone we
have an affordable housing crisis to protect or this project does nothing for homelessness
if the homes still aren't affordable and there's no guarantee that they will be we know the truth
that the scientific literature is not nearly enough to estimate the safety for this oak
approving this plan would harm the ecosystem and habitat surrounding the oak which would be a
death sentence for this sacred ancient being we can come up with a plan that honors this ancient
oak the first nations and the citizens of harupa much much better and we want to see
a better plan that ensures more safety more preservation more for the first nations and more
for the citizens of harupa and not just lining the pockets of this um business that will make
most of the profits thank you mac good evening honorable mayor and members of the harupa valley
city council my name is mac maxwell and i'm a biologist and civil servant to the state of california
i grew up in harupa valley and attended primary and secondary school here my first job was along
the foothills of the harupa mountains where i was exposed to the ecology of the region and i
educated the public about natural history as it stands i opposed the implementation of the rio
piss vista specific plan if anything it is undeniable that the public isn't able to gauge the extent
of impacts that this project would cause i work with environmental law and regulation and i can
tell you and everyone else here that is present today that redacting the biological and cultural
impact assessments keeps the public ignorance about the extent to which the specific plan will
impact the local ecological and cultural resources and make no mistake this is intentional
it is easier to get support for something or at least remain ambivalent when you don't have
all the facts i hope you can stand with me against this project not only for its own known impacts
that are clear as day but also against this information deficit it is not normal and we cannot just
shrug it off and treat it as normal the people of harupa valley deserve to know the facts about the
implica implement implications of developments in our city we can talk economic gain all day
but what are we sacrificing we can do better than this thank you for your time
and after that Aaron Nichols hello hi um i don't want this to be an us versus them kind of situation
against the union folk or the ecological and environmental folk but as it stands the real vista
current plan i do oppose until we do have enough more accurate and more concurrent
research and development when it comes to that i myself am a union worker i understand the
impact of an of a union job can do to your life it hasn't proved my life significantly
and i do believe that like union jobs are super important and especially also housing is a super
important thing we do have an affordable housing crisis in this state of california and so i just
as is um i do not believe that the current plan for the real vista is the right move to take i do
believe we do need to have all the input of our community here um to take account of thank you
so much for your time thank you Aaron Nichols if you have to uh donated the card so uh six minutes for
him and then after that is rob rob good evening city council thank you for taking the time tonight
to hear everybody's comments my name is Aaron Nichols and tonight i'm speaking on the half of
myself as a harupa valley resident and i think before i make any comments i do want to acknowledge
that we are in a biological diversity hotspot in california right where we are in harupa valley
is a biological hotspot we're one of two in the continental united states it's us and then
florida everglades i want to correct the record uh also the photos that were shown were taken
very selectively of this project area this is not just vacant land this is area that's occupied by
250 acres of coastal sage scrub that's where your name comes from the city of harupa
uh that sage scrub is occupied by california nat catcher and eleven other sensitive species
designated by the state as sensitive while dumping and other activities have been common out there
in the past since the property owner has started to restrict access just a little bit with something
they should have done a long long time ago you now have people out there riding horses you
have bike riders you have hikers you have dog walkers even in the middle of summer you have
people out there using the space it is not just vacant land it's very different from
a lot of the other projects that i think have come before you you need to acknowledge that
it's it's also full of hills there's rock out crops there's rock out crops that are the size of
buses out there i want to talk about the timeline this project this 1992 project that actually
originated in 1989 with the county of riverside much like the oak it is a relic we were not aware
that the oak was rediscovered in 1989 nor in 1992 the oak was rediscovered in 1998 and then its age
was determined in 2009 so when we look at the 1992 plan and we say well the 1992 plan doesn't
provide protection for the oak it's because we didn't know about it speaking of the 1992 plan
it's important to acknowledge that that plan is not a valid option for a number of reasons i don't
want to i don't want to start talking about sequa here i've been trying to avoid that because i know
you probably hate that sequa i but i have to sequa requires supplemental review for projects
when new information arises even if they've been approved as long as there has not been a
discretionary action of all the discretionary actions that needed to be approved that new
information trigger happens and there's a number of discretionary approvals for the 1992 project
some of those are discretionary approvals that you have to make that have not happened yet
therefore the new significant information trigger is set what has happened since 1992 in 1993
california not catcher was listed as endangered under the endangered species act that's the federal
endangered species act in 1998 the oak was rediscovered in 2009 it was determined to be
13 to 18 000 years old in 2004 the riverside county of shcp was developed i i need not go on
this 1992 plan is not a valid option it would clearly need to go and undergo and supplemental
environmental review at that the june the first planning commission meeting mr kraut who i
actually admire quite a lot admitted this he admitted that the the plan and i sent you the video
you have it in your inbox you can go watch it before they realized that presenting the 1992
plan next to the new plan was a viable strategy they admitted that this 1992 plan is not a financially
viable option it cannot be built they couldn't build it when they present the two next to each
other as was just on the screen before it switched it's just outright a lie it's manipulation it's
trying to get you to approve this new plan under a false premise i want to talk about scoping
i i go to a number of different city council meetings i live in group of valley but i i sort of
do uh conservation on my weekends that's what i dedicated my life to i went to a rancho kukamanga
meeting a few years ago they had a small piece of land it's about actually the same size of this
and prior to doing anything prior to doing environmental impact report prior to doing
studies out there they invited the community for months to come in and give them their feedback
they had boards up all around the room they had sticker notes they had all kinds of options
for people to provide input the city of haruba has done nothing as far as public involvement in
scoping you know what you did you did an environmental justice meeting after the d e i r was released
on thanksgiving and you invited about five people to i i only saw the meeting because i
just happened to be scrolling your website it wasn't it wasn't a public invitation there's
been absolutely no public scoping on this plan i'm running it low on time uh so i just want to
i just want to offer myself i i did send you an email i've offered to dedicate a thousand hours
of my own time towards helping you and your city create a preserve a hundred acre preserve
around the harupa oak and i stand by that if you reject this plan which is a gut punch it's not
just a gut punch to harupa it's a gut punch to california it's a gut punch to the world this oak
has international recognition and i will help you protect it if you reject this plan thank you very
much for your time good evening mayor council members my name is robert rommelson i am
what the iron workers local 416 representing 3200 members much of them that live in this
these communities we are here tonight in support of this project and asked your support as well
this project will bring much to the community not only has a developer made a commitment to hire
local but the developer will bring industrial business and much needed residential to boost
the local economy overall and create more housing you know after watching the presentation
and seeing this the developer has made a commitment no they they mood the buffer they i see the
the how the dumping areas right that creates you know you know homelessness and all that other
stuff out there that could happen and it gets worse over time right that's you know that's a
negative for the city of harupa right by building this development you're going to be able to
actually monitor what's going on around that uh tree right um you know it's just an overall
perfect project for the city of harupa and i urge you to vote yes tonight thank you
and john torus and after that it's not really a torus thank you good evening it's clearly
getting very late um thank you mayor mayor pro tem council members uh my name is john torus
professor of anthropology linguistics and american indian studies at mount sentinel college um i
pardon i'm reading i want to make sure i stay on time so uh as my students my students can attest
to the fact that i can get off on tangents and i don't want to try to do that so um i'm also an
enrolled member of the Navajo nation and i'm also a consulting anthropologist for the quiche nation
i'm here to speak in support of the development of the Rio Vista project these are words actually
i never thought i would say i mean in the day i was all about land back and anti-development
but this ends up being a very unusual experiment i think uh the land um the proposal of this land
stewardship this partnership i think is a unique compromise the realities of the 21st century are
really looking at us that is a reality that we all must face um i've been in the profession of
resource management for over 30 years and i've never experienced an innovative approach
to this land management style for over 20,000 years the indigenous people of the hemisphere
has managed these landscapes other than the farming communities most of them have been
managing these landscapes these landscapes that we see today this is the sage crab the pinion
pine uh oak groves etc these are not wild landscapes these are anthropogenic landscapes
these were created by humans to create this symbiotic relationship with the environment
that includes all their food all their medicine all the resources building materials everything they
need the carrying capacity many of these landscapes are much lower in a wild state there are much
more mixed communities but that's not what we see out there we actually see groups of plants
that are together and planted together by people in the past including the oak tree i mean you know
the oak tree itself is is growing in a place that traditionally that species doesn't grow
which may be by by design and not by accident this traditional ecological knowledge
is still remains the tribal members still are know how to use traditional ecological knowledge
this knowledge and this sort of spiritual magic has worked for thousands of years
but the key people also live in the 21st century which is why they have graduate level
degree to people a biologist and paleontologist and anthropologist etc to help work in these kinds
of projects not only are the key people the actual lineal descendants of the people from this area
compared to other tribes that might want interest at this point they are uniquely equipped to be
the stewards of the property and combine traditional ecological knowledge and modern western science
methodologies i know any vote for the development that could lead to the damage of the tree would
be a political career killer for sure but the descendants of the people who have perhaps even
planted that tree it would be a great loss to a great spirit combining their knowledge western
science the Kich nation is uniquely suited to be the land stewards the ancestors intended
to be okay thank you thank you quality take three o'clock when they start this good and good evening
my name is harelia torres i'm an indigenous archaeology and cultural monitor with the Kich nation
gabellano ban emission indians i come to you today to speak about the harupa hills rio vista
project i want to let you know as an indigenous archaeologist and tribal monitor here in southern
california area i am in full support of the kich nation gabellano ban emission indians
as the rightful stewards of the land and the true aboriginal lineal descendants of the la basin
which is known to us today as los angeles county parts of orange county riverside county and
salmanadino county as well as southern california channel up the southern channel islands and most
importantly as the hereditary caretakers of the sacred hills and archaeological sites of the ancestral
kich village of haruvangna which is in the city limits of harupa i want to take a moment to applaud
the true collaboration of richland communities and the kich nation gabellano ban emission indians
i know that they have diligently been working with one another to protect haruvangna the palmers oak
to ensure that the oak and the designated lands around it are safe today and for generations to come
please understand for the kich this is not a hobby this is not just a career this is not a special
interest this is their honorable obligation to protect the kich lands to their protect their
ancestors to protect the living this and for their living descendants and to the future generations
that will follow as well as to preserve and protect their rich history the kich nation takes
this responsibility seriously and i want to really reiterate this is not a hobby they have
been practicing and cultivating the lands for thousands of years and for those in the audience
who after the last meeting um asked can you even take care of that much land i felt that it was
disrespectful i want you to know the kich nation has formally educated certified and
trained professional staff and tribal members who understand and integrate both tribal cultural
knowledge and western practices of education in biology archaeology paleontology and kich resource
management i asked you hear my words with an open heart i hope my words ease your concerns and
for the protection and management of the land the kich nation rightfully hold dear to them
as well they acknowledge as their ancestral sacred lands and ceremonial sites i urge
harupa city council to vote in favor and entrusting the kich nation gabellano banamish
in indians as the stewards of their own ancestral land thank you thank you i can't read the last
thing that says jonathan i want to say jonathan r and then after that is susan phillips
good evening um i'm a local area resident for about 16 years now uh lifelong uh admire
and student of the natural world i applaud your guys's due diligence on this subject particularly
for the for the oak um and i also uh apologize for its efforts to and concessions to try to protect
the soak but uh i feel like the stakes are very high uh i i feel like everyone in this room knows
the importance of of this tree uh for cultural and and biological reasons um i i i posed a project
as is particularly around the spot around the oak uh i i don't think enough has been done to
assure that it will survive and i want you guys to think of a future where it's approved as is
um maybe maybe the protections that have been laid out are great they work well everything's
fine awesome maybe they're not maybe that tree parishes does this group of value want to be
remembered is the city that approved the project that killed one of the most remarkable organisms
on the earth uh please please reconsider the project as designed uh thank you i'm not going to talk
long but i did get uh given someone's time for three extra minutes routine tell more um i wanted
to my name is susan phillips i wanted to just talk about a few things uh the first of which well
earlier i said we've it's possible by 2050 harupa valley will be more like phoenix than it is like harupa
valley if we don't make change what i didn't say is that we have until about 2030 to really make
that happen and so my first suggestion to you is with a big project like this that covers a lot
of open land the land that does the best job of creating cooling and all kinds of other benefits
is that actually you wait until 2030 to consider and approve this project and i'm not kidding
not being facetious we are looking at some serious cascading events that will happen
very in the very near future this project has been conceived of for decades i don't think it's
actually that big of a deal to wait a little bit longer to see what the climate does to us to see
what we can do to improve the climate um what are the concerns of this project that hasn't been
mentioned is that it's in a high fire severity zone the entire project is that means that none
of the housing will be eligible for fire insurance this is a thing that i wrote about to the planning
commission i have not heard it addressed um all state state farm these entities are not
ensuring houses the insurance will have to go through the state i don't know the answer
regarding um the insurability of warehouses which also have a fire risk attached
um in terms of truck trips i wanted just to point out that sikwa and eir's are always weak on
cumulative impact so i just wanted to point out that there's about 33 000 truck trips per day
in harupa valley and that this would be adding that 814 truck trips per day more of different
kinds we've debated that um the other thing i wanted to talk about was the definition of
warehouses there's been a lot of talk about that tonight um it's true that they're not warehouses
if you define them from only a labor perspective um in terms of distribution but if you define them
from a built environment perspective from the perspective of a building they're tilt-ups they
have massive concrete um pads uh land use they use energy probably the energy usage will actually
be higher if it's a manufacturing usage um in terms of greenhouse gases and carbon emissions
those are the two worst things that are considered you know as part of the need to have a statement
of overriding consideration i'm not at all convinced that because of the really tremendous
um danger that we're in we're in a danger zone that actually i think all of the statements of
overriding consideration should be rethought um nature itself provides benefits that are incalculable
so to enumerate those is a near impossibility the last thing i wanted to say is about housing um
harupa valley is out of compliance with rina and it's out of compliance in three of the four areas
in terms of a grading scorecard that the orange county registered registrar does
uh the latest uh the latest grades that harupa valley gets are an F in very low income housing
an F in low income housing an F in moderate income housing an A in high in above average high
income housing so you've got some work to do this is a housing project but it's really not
hitting the right housing targets that will benefit this community um to have housing and VMT
calculations that assume that people who are going to be living across the street are going to be
working at these uh within that entity is is uh is disingenuous when the houses are going to be
costing over seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars a piece as we saw in one of the slides
i know it's a hard deliberation it's been a long night i appreciate your time and consideration
thank you so much kara grant kara grant good evening council my name is kara grant and i am
counsel for the gabriel and abandon mission indians quiche nation the only decision that
affords the oak and the numerous other quiche tribal resources and sacred places the adequate
protection preservation and mitigation is the city council's approval of the proposed project
the prior project which is fully entitled has no mitigations or conditions to protect the oak
for any of the thirteen other known quiche resources and sacred sites
a stay of the proposed project by litigation from the opposition will leave those indigenous
resources and sacred places completely unprotected and at great risk of irreparable harm a risk that
has been exponentially increased by the disclosure of their locations and existence on social media
by the very individuals and entities here tonight opposing the project in the name of conservation
if the project is approved and a sequel or other lawsuit challenging the approval is filed
the quiche nation will promptly intervene and seek an order from the court requiring the
petitioner to post a bond commensurate with a irreparable harm the quiche and its resources will
sustain from delaying the implementation of the mitigations and the quiche stewardship
the opposition has yet to provide substantial evidence showing that the project mitigations
the 450 and 550 foot buffer zones the quiche's monitoring plan for all phases of construction
of the sacred oak and a thousand feet around the sacred oak the perpetual stewardship of all open
space areas allowing protection of their cultural biological and ceremonial resources and places
are not sufficient any member of this council that votes no on this project is voting against
the reunion of these indigenous lands and resources with their first protector the quiche nation
thank you we have chairman androsalas also quick question there's a couple of them that say
they're donating their time to you but we're only allowed to donate one extra time that we
let's not be quick good evening council mayor ladies and gentlemen
i really i'm honored to be here my name is androsalas and i am the tribal chair of the
gabraleno banda mission indian indians quiche nation i am lenial descendant of the indigenous
people who roamed this area of the los angeles basin orange county riverside region
the channel islands i'm a direct lenial descendant to those indigenous people
and i also became part of the spanish mexican and americans who came to settle here
like the tracheals the lugeaus that recited right here our manta areas that they call spanish
town those were my grandfathers as we became mixtices but today i want to let everybody know
here today that we are for the project you know i was in the back room there earlier
answering questions for individuals that were there and didn't know why they were here
and they were going to oppose they didn't know why because they thought we were here
because we were being paid by the developers could you imagine that paid
these individuals came and were brought here with four large pizzas to oppose this project
this project that my ancestors have been for years thousands of years
protecting this particular site everybody mentions the oak and the oak is significant
and it's been there for over 13,000 years old years and why it's been there is because of my
ancestors that have been taking care of that area there's important resources that are
significant to our people there rock shelters ceremonial sites nobody talks about that
nobody cares about that but we do we're here today because this project in the past has already
been approved and when it was approved there was no protective measures nothing to protect
the sacred oak the sacred sites the area the geographic area that we call home but with this new
development and believe me we were opposing this project in my correct gentleman we were
opposing it and opposing we've been involved not since 2018 that's when we did our sacred
lands file but we've been involved in 2015 we've been involved in the 1990s we've been involved in
the 1950s we've been in the 1940s 19 20s 1800s 1700s we've always been involved that's why that tree
exists there along with those historic or prehistoric rock shelters that are there but nobody talks
about that so I'm here in hopes that the council will finally give us the indigenous people here
the opportunity areas that we have been restricted private areas that we were not able no more to
come in ceremony and bring our children tell our stories that you guys would support this project
so that we could again be the stewards of our home lands this area is important to me like it
is to everybody here the oak tree that's all we heard tonight but there's significant sites
there my father's no longer with us he's passed he's on his journey to that spiritual world
but this area location meant a lot to him which is why he pushed to make that sacred lands
file before he left the earth so I come to you all tonight in hopes that you support
helping us help you helping the community but most of all helping preserve our sacred sites there
to preserve them in perpetuity forever and with them when we're not here all the audience here
that our year could help fulfill our legacy in protecting that's that sacred area
just like my ancestors did but everybody forgets the indigenous part of that
why everybody's here all these people here are visitors in our home lands
but yet we're confined of not coming into our areas and preserving them and protecting them
so I come to you and ask you please we want to work with each other help us protect preserve
and help us be the stewards once again over our home lands thank you good night
not matt i'm assuming it's tough to miss good evening mr mayor mr pro tem mayor and council
my name is matt you to team as i'm the biologist for the gabellano ban a mission indians kitch
nation and i am very honored to be here to speak on behalf of our tribe and what we have
tried to provide in the uh because what we're hearing tonight is exactly what our concerns
have always been and because of these concerns we've always had the stance of avoidance
however the reality that came upon to us is what the reality is showing tonight
that the only option on the table right now for preservation is this site plan
is this option being presented to you tonight all other options such as leave as is no protection
such as use the original plan no protection and then to halt or to keep this
plan to wait many years is also now making all of the resources that we're trying to protect
now vulnerable during that time span that there's no protection and so our purpose our
goal is for the protection and preservation of the plants animals and the tribal cultural
resources and our only option to do that is with this plan that's the double-edged sword we're
dealing with we would love avoidance but there's no billionaire that's coming in here and saying
hey i'm gonna pay to make it so that there's no building on there no one's done that yet
we're hoping that that will be a godsend coming down but the reality is the only option on the
table for protection of our resources and the resources of everybody here is this plan and so
that's why we're in support of this plan because this provides protection in the immediate time
not in a later time that we don't know what's going to happen in that time being the destruction
that's already happening right now so our plans for this land incorporate re-engaging the ability
for the community not just us as a tribe for the community to then regain the ability to have
medicine regain the ability to have food regain the ability to have the the the beautiful aesthetics
that come with natural lands that they can now then rest their soul rest their mind in these areas
that's not going to be afforded in any of these other options than that one option that's provided
today and that's what we're concerned with we want this to happen we want to be able to provide
for not only our tribe's future in terms of protecting our resources but for this community
as well and our plans for that land far surpass any other conservation ideas right now and that's
what we want to be able to provide and right now our only way to provide it is by passing this plan i
thank you so much for your time Sophia Pinar no Sophia Pinar okay Elaine Brown after that
Daniel Garcia hello hello council members and my name is Elaine thank you for taking the time
tonight to listen to all of our public comments i appreciate it so like many others have spoken
today i'm opposed to this project because it proposes to destroy a living ecosystem around
some of the oldest living plants on the earth we do not believe that the 450 foot buffer zone
guarantees the protection of the oak and it also does not address some major concerns with the
development including the urban heat island effect and how it could impact the oak's access
to groundwater this EIR was approved despite lack of scientific rigor so for these particular
reasons i urge you to vote no on the Rio Vista specific plan as it has been presented today
i think in california we have the luxury of taking for granted a lot of the biodiversity
implants and animals and insects that we observe on a daily basis there's so many different ecosystems
here so sometimes it's easy to forget that we are in the midst of a global biodiversity crisis
with declines in population of birds pollinators all across the world now more than ever our remaining
open spaces are super important and just preserving slivers of open space is no longer
enough we have the information now to see that this could cause lasting effects on our future
as people while these populations are in decline rather than waiting until the populations are
threatened or extinct we cannot fully predict or imagine the effects of having far less biodiversity
far fewer insects and far fewer birds and although this project may create immediate
benefits to the community i believe that is not enough in the sense that i just hope that
it could be reevaluated with a little bit more research as to how it could possibly
affect the local environment long-term thank you for listening mayor council members thank you
for listening to me tonight i would like to thank all of our sheriffs first and foremost and i would
like to pay my respects to armando's father-in-law i stand here as a community member
um i'm sorry i'm thinking about my grandma lost area not too long ago i was born uh just 10 miles
away from the oak maybe closer my grandparents moved to this beautiful city just 35 years ago
i'm give or take i went to prawl telemetry to mission middle and to rub it a high school
all which stand within a mile or two of this oak and i'm not here to tell you about why we should
protect the oak we all agree that it's the third oldest plant in the world and and it needs to be
protected instead i'm here to share the story of what the oak represents
council members i'm tired of being lied to i'm tired of being manipulated and what do i mean by that
well there's a lot of falsities about this plant you guys talk about a three hundred and fifty
thousand dollar payment to protect the oak you guys talk about how that's going to continue with the
HOA fees you guys talk about a 22 million dollar CFD that's going to go to helping our community
all of these are false and why do i say that well yes they're going to give us 22 million
dollars with this development but 20 million dollars are going to come up the tax revenue
from these housings why don't you clarify that the HOA fees we can build the homes without the
light industry and the oak can still be protected i came in here today with no clue of what i was
going to say i have no paper in pen telling me what i was going to say i walked in i saw the logo
it says city of rupa valley a community of communities and all i see here in this room is people with
outside interests i see the labor union people which they have great facial hair thank you for
your hard work i see the developers you guys look like a million dollars awesome i see the indian
tribe thank you for your deep heritage i deeply respect that but you guys are here because you're
going to get paid a lot of money if this project goes through
lastly i think it's important to know that your family owns a trucking company
chris barajas i think it's important to know for the people to know that you make software for
these logistics companies and you guys talk about light industry 140 acres of light industry that's
going to come with this project oh it's just light industry it's not going to bring problems to
your city no ladies and gentlemen they're lying to you they're manipulating you it's 800 truck
trucks a day that's four thousand trucks per week and here i have
the light industry area by the 60 and the 15 in rupa valley so light industry there you go
and here is a good worth you of what that looks like to me ladies and gentlemen that is warehousing
so maybe no it's not going to be a fulfillment center and amazon warehouse but yes it is going
to change the narrative of our of our city if we're willing to build light industry warehousing
thank you for for lying to everybody on that 350 short feet away from the oak what else are
we willing to do build warehouses on the riverbed let's save our city hupa valley let's stop being
light to and manipulate it i'm tired of it that's your time daniel and it's not just
save the oak or develop it can be both it can be both we can develop the 17 hundred homes
we can develop the schools and still protect the oak it's just about not building the light
industry so that's your time all this business part thank you thank you so much for your time
i appreciate it we have Victoria Jones good evening Sonya Pena donated her time to me i don't think
i'll need it but i'm just letting you know that she gave me consent to do that good evening i'll
put my glasses on because i always always come to city council is prepared with something
in writing i don't swing from the hip because i'll stumble on my words good evening honorable
mayor silva mayor pro tem council members and city staff it's no secret california is in a housing
shortage crisis the rio vista project will reap one completed over three million dollars annually
from city taxes which helps the city it's not profit just to the developer
we all have to live somewhere we all have to pay our fair share and yes taxes make the city run
that's business that's how we do it no surprise there i'm here in support of the preservation
of sacred sites in the harupa hills rio vista project i wish to express my complete support
for the preservation of the sacred sites within the harupa hills rio vista project area
particularly the sacred oak and surrounding archaeological sites as you are aware
these sacred sites whole profound cultural and spiritual significance to the quiche nation
gabrilino band of mission indians the ancestral tribe of this area which has safeguarded these
lands for thousands of years the quiche nation recognized as the original stewards of this
geographical region has an unbroken connection to these lands as documented through oral history
and archaeological evidence the preservation of these sacred sites is not only a matter of
cultural significance but also of spiritual responsibility it is imperative that these areas
be protected in perpetuity ensuring that the legacy of the quiche nation and the sacredness of
these lands are honored and preserved for future generations i fully support the request for the
city of harupa valley to hand over the stewardship of these lands to the quiche nation allowing them
to continue their role as the rightful protectors of this region this action would demonstrate
respect for the cultural heritage of the area and reinforce the city's commitment to preserving
the rich history and sacred sites that define this community given their experience depth of
knowledge and expertise in the history of this area that was documented and known as harunga
their involvement will ensure that future generations can continue to benefit from the
natural and cultural heritage of this region thank you for your careful consideration of this
critical historic issue i urge you to act in favor of preserving these sacred sites and to
entrust the quiche nation in their commitment to protection the second note just quickly is that
the developer the city and the tribal endowment is for operating cost it is not for profit we don't
do this to make money we do this because everything has to be sustainable you drive a car you have to
put gas in it where does the money come from that's how it works the endowment is for operating cost
and the honor to do that thank you very much roose britsington i don't know if i said it right but
rooseby who's that my name is Ruth britsington um from stand up for mother earth
um i had like all these notes prepared and everything but i've been sitting here listening to everybody's
comments their oppositions the people who are for the project i was also at the planning commissions
meeting and um it just seems over and over again the overriding theme seems to be that if
this current project that is planned as it is is not approved then the 1992 plan is going to be
miraculously resurrected and put into effect and thereby not protecting the harupa oak so i think um
erin eckles talked a little bit on this about how that 1992 plan cannot go into effect it's way
to stale it would have to have some kind of supplemental um environmental impact report done
and and certainly the harupa oak would be addressed in that's a supplement uh er the other thing is
none of the alternatives that were in the er um mentioned the harupa oak at all and i find it
particularly shameful that the developer actually seems to threaten to keep the existing plan it's
this is your choice project denial will keep the existing plan that was purportedly approved in 1992
although there is no record of such approval on sequinet so i don't know what the true status of
that is my other understanding is that as far back as 2020 the keych nation was asking for 45
acres to create a preserve for the harupa oak now i don't know what happened to that 45 acres but
they're sure not getting it uh what are they getting 27 no just for surrounding the whole
the oak so anyway so the 45 acres was supposed to be specifically a preserve for the harupa oak
so um as one of the gentlemen said recently that he feels like it's this plan or nothing and i
don't think that we should um look at it that way it's not this plan or nothing it's this plan
or perhaps a better plan as your time with more protection for the harupa oak thank you thank you
western templeton western templeton and after that george reese western templeton and we'll go to
george reese come to we'll move on to adriana reels i'm sorry adriana sorry hello good evening
this is my first time like ever speaking in front of city council so i'm a little nervous so
um yeah but it was like interesting you know sitting here and watching you know the developers make
their presentation community members and developers like just speak about the project um and i'm coming
from a place as someone who lives in the land empire um i occasionally work here in harupa as well
um and i'm here to ask you to oppose the existing project as it is currently
um like as someone who lives in the land empire i see projects like this all the time like
warehouses coming in developing land like we are we are witnessing such like historical land
grab of open land being developed just for warehouses and it's so interesting how like the term warehouse
is being dodged so much when it's literally the exact same thing like it's just being rebranded
but it's it's really just a warehouse in my opinion light industrial business part call it what
you want it's it's a warehouse um it's a concrete wall that's going to have an immense impact on
oak no amount of environmental mitigation is going to keep that oak as it is right now um so
the project can be developed yeah we can create these plans the conservation plans around it but
it's not going to be the same in any way this is a biodiversity hotspot um and a lot of the like
arguments um in favor of this project is the jobs the jobs is like all we hear all the time but
it's going to create jobs it's going to create jobs like how much are we willing to sacrifice
for jobs there are no jobs on a debt planet like the air the water the land that we step on is
invaluable how do you not see that this matters more than simply a job like without the health
of this planet there are no jobs like that should be the number one priority as humanity to take
care of this land above everything else and of course each other so we're willing to sacrifice
all of that just for some people to get more richer someone i don't like it doesn't make sense
like so that's my main content contesting with this project is like it's not sustainable it's
the environmental impact report does not make sense it's it's not scientifically valid like
so much like testing it it just isn't sustainable and i think there are alternative ways and things
we can do better um it's crazy that we live in a world where we have to you know in order to get
conservation we have to have development it's that's that's ridiculous we can conserve things
without developing immediately over them this is as we know the oldest living tree in California
and potentially like North America um so why are we so willing to develop around it it we should
be all together in trying to hey this is a historic site we should save this this has so much value
and we're so willing to give that up and sacrifice just for to make a place it looks exactly like
everywhere else it looks the same to everything thank you Laura Salas we have Laura Salas
no okay we have a Sandra i can't read the last name but it's Sandra V okay what a brandy Salas
do we have a brandy Salas no okay um then erin mesa savannah salas same thing
can that she already spoke right Peter she already spoke she can't take
yeah no no it's yeah okay uh mernotores after that mesaki mandosa after mernotores
good evening mayor city council members and staff aside from protecting the hudupa oak there is
something else remarkable happening tonight what is happening tonight is a form of reparations
restoring land to the quiche nation a native tribe with deep roots in this area
this is rare but a significant act by voting yes you are not only preserving a piece of nature
the hudupa oak but you are also contributing to the broader movement for justice and reparations
potentially setting a standard for future developers and developments across california
and the united states thank you yeah it's a donated extra time you have donated time yes
hello my name is mesaki mandosa i'm currently a fourth-year student at yuzis and yago studying
mathematics economics and urban planning i've been a resident of group of alleys since i was
at least two years old i'm 20 now so that makes me a resident for 18 years and the last two years
the last three years as i've been learning more about urban planning i have come to be
someone who is pro development but also pro open space however in regards to real vista
my general argument is that while there are flaws to the project i don't see a credible alternative
that can achieve housing and employment goals while preserving open space based on what i have
seen heard and experienced over the last two years as mentioned earlier we are in a housing
crisis which for me is particularly personal to be able to attend yuzis and yago i sleep in a
walk-in closet for eight hundred fifty dollars a month and i still split a one bedroom apartment
with three other people considering i thought i came out of the closet at 13 on to go back inside
at 19 because of the housing crisis this has made our housing crisis a top concern for me
there isn't enough housing according to alex horowitz an economist at the pew housing
policy initiative with real vista the higher density housing counts towards lower to moderate
income households any proposed solution that does not include denser and more my more housing
development is merely rearranging musical chairs on the titanic i also believe that the light
industrial and business park aspects of the plan especially with the upcoming inland empire
technical trade center that will train vocational workers can bring decent jobs while avoiding
much of the negative impacts associated with heavy industry granted i am concerned to see some
uses allowed like cold storage self storage or general storage comes to fruition but i think
the main concern of e-commerce uses like amazon warehouses aren't allowed and i think one of the
planning commissioners also said that the individual buildings are too small to hold warehouses anyway
especially with testimony from union workers i think the mix of uses from housing light industrial
business park and open space has a decent balance even if concerns remain
having said all that though i am also pro open space and understand the concerns of people
who wish to see further urban sprawl prevented even especially as we do have something special
to protect how though are we to reconcile a growing population of people who would benefit
from housing and jobs with the need to conserve the natural environment in the last two years in
group of alley and in san diego i have consistently advocated for denser and infill development not
just as a solution to the a crippling housing crisis but to also prevent further sprawl that
could prevent natural resources such as the herpa oak denser development saves land water
and other resources according to the environmental protection agency for instance in real vista
the highest high density residential area has four times the amount of housing in the same amount
of area representing how developing more densely can either house more people which we need or
use less land which is also desirable as eric walker said in his book on public transportation
called human transit cities are a geomac a geometry problem with finite land that must be used
as efficiently as possible yet throughout the last two years from the beginning of advocating
for infill development i've been yelled at jeered and his stat for advocating denser infill
development this experience has led me to believe that there is no significant swell of people who
would support infill development as a move away from greenfield quite the opposite during consideration
of the last bottom of development last December comes a number of karmona label density a developer
giveaway too many people in harupa have a position of only low density development and as soon as
my name was called up to comment on a sendable nine ordinance last november that would promote
more infill development the jeers hissing and glaring ensued if we refuse density and infill
development if we refuse to develop open space my fear is if real vista is halted and some are all
uses stripped back as some people advocating for we would regress on development i believe that
harupa would greatly benefit from some people may value conservation more than economic development
a standpoint i think a reasonable person can arrive at but as my statistics professor once said
we must understand that there are no solutions only trade-offs for a halted or scaling back of
real vista for conservation i fear the trade-off would be a loss of housing jobs and entrepreneurship
opportunities with no alternative to replicate those benefits thus i am inclined to support real
vista could it be improved from its current state sure i do encourage the city to push the industrial
and business uses if as far away as possible from the yolk or to make the development more
compact by building taller and narrower and this would free more space as well and i think including
language that explicitly prevents warehousing and has specific measures baked in to prevent
primary primarily storage and warehousing uses would be a good idea i personally thought
council member kamona did raise some value concerns around that aspect but although i don't see an
alternative to read vista on the horizon i hope that can change to better save natural
resources like the harupa oak while still allowing our economy to grow i hope more people can see the
benefits of and call for denser infill and mixed use development compared to other cities in the
region doing so and make harupa valley a leader in creating a better city to live thank you
Jose what uh no i'm sorry Jose Herrera
no christian devore how's it going um i've lived here for 31 years i used to come here all the time
with the sam's western where with my grandfather to get ship our horses sorry for my language
there's one thing my grandfather taught me and that was to call it like it is and i feel like i'm
standing in a room full of liars i see people up there lying i see developers lying i see union
members lying i see indigenous people all due respect lying i feel like there's a lot of ways
we can go about this by providing houses and jobs without using that entire area what about the
area off of canal street with all those housing paths that have just been sitting there for five
six seven years were we ever going to finish those about the area that used to have club metro
just an empty law off of mission that's a big area we can put something there why do we have to
use this area everybody's talking about you know oh i see all their alternatives what about all
the empty other space we have in this town oh no just the way i see it thank you Veronica Sanchez
thank you mayor and council members thank you to the community for taking the time to show your
concerns and to be here tonight my name is Veronica Sanchez and i come to join i come to you as
a concerned citizen community member and living in a person that's lived here for 35 years
and a small business owner i see a council of five districts being represented here of our
community tonight and we have only heard from one council showing concern and one comment from
another i wish i would have heard a little bit more from some of the other council members to speak
about this project i have spoken to many of our neighbors and i'm here to share their concerns
the rear vista project what does light industrial bring to us brings pollution more traffic
long time to get to our homes and to our children's from schools these projects will eliminate small
businesses as they will be bringing bigger businesses and bigger corporations all small
businesses have been here for many years of small mom and pop shops have been contributors to our
schools our kids um sports and big businesses don't do that they don't support they don't support
our children small businesses do this project you say brings um open space but i think what i think
of what our community thinks of what open space we don't see eye to eye on that we don't have the
same vision what i see is open space is the views of the mountains the beauty of nature the quiet
walks not having to worry about trucks the low traffic in our neighborhoods and being able to
have horse trails in more open space i was sharing with the friend how interesting that here
where i live at you're able to see hawks in the mountains you're able to see bad rabbits in
your front yard you're able to just hear peace and quiet and why is that is because a group of
valley people came for that open space they came so that they could have so they can have
the quietness and that they were able to um it's the reason why they brought their families here
this project also says affordable housing but for who not for the people here in community not
for the people here in the community not for the children's children's to come i think it's more
to be able to compliment other people's from other cities to bring their ideas of what they want
which is big city us here we want the open space for us to be able to not to have crowded
crowded schools our cars our more cars in the neighborhoods and be able to have
we won't be able to have protection from law enforcement because we have too many homes
my dad was also a union worker and he drove three hours a day bringing us to open space
and like many dads and many dads made the sacrifices here for their families this project will not
support our community's family values the oak is a symbol of the livelihood and representation
of what group of valley and what we want for the best for generations to come we are a
prideful community with rich roots and culture and we like our open space in our quiet neighborhoods
thank you
hi my name is Robert Ramirez I'm also a small business owner here in her group of valley
I've been here for over 20 years I'm also a united states marine and my daughter is a united states
marine she's also a sergeant in the marine corps we support our community just to let you guys know
that this is a Trojan horse you guys know it you guys know it it's a Trojan horse
okay I respect the union workers you guys are I much respect to you much love to you guys
the Kish nation much respect much love but what will your ancestors say Kish nation
what will your ancestors say about this what you know I have you know I come from a
long heritage of Hispanic family and it's all about respect protecting our land
taking care of it I assure you that the your Kish ancestors will be rolling in their graves
when they if they were to find out that you were going to put two million dollars of industrial
land with warehouses what an embarrassment to who they are I don't mean any disrespect Kish
tribe I I I'm trying to stay as respectful if I can I assure you also all you guys here
you know the you guys you guys will not lose your jobs you will still continue to work
because one project doesn't get approved doesn't mean you will not feed your families
you you will just move on to the next project and you will feed your families from that project
but what will you destroy by approving this you will destroy
a 13 000 to an 18 000 dollar plant this is this plant is a heartbeat to our earth it's a connection
to who we are where we come from I was going to start this conversation and I have to take a
step back Armando Carmona I'm very sorry for your loss much love much respect to you I wish your
wife very good health I I mean that from the bottom of my heart that's how I wanted to start it
I got off on the wrong foot I apologize but again this is the Trojan horse guys these car salesmen
this gentleman in a blue suit he's just a car salesman guys he's a fast-talking car salesman
that's what these people are they're in it for the money you know it we know it
guys you work for us for the community you don't work for these millionaires and whatever they are
you work for us look at look at the people that are here how often do you get this kind of a feedback
now we're not saying we're rethink this let's let's think about this let's reevaluate it
don't make a decision today let's extend it let's work on it we are still a good community
there is still room for growth my kids I have two kids with an apartment is done on
on by Lowe's both of them are moving out you know why because it's thirty three hundred dollars
for one bedroom one bedroom this is what you guys are building here you guys these are
affordable homes the lady just said it we got F's all the way across the board guys pay attention
Leslie let's think about this mayor bergsen Chris Armando let's work together on this one
Kish nation I'm sorry I don't know where you come from on this one I I you know I come from deep
roots and and I feel that that it's a sellout this is a sellout you guys are selling out
who we are this is look at the look at the community coming together to protect something
and the Kish people wanted gone like it makes no sense look at look at all these people that that
love who we are and where we come from I just see this as a complete sellout you know it's about
respect again this this bush is it's part of the heartbeat of not Krupa Valley of the earth
it's a heartbeat it's attached to the earth it's been here for 18,000 years now this is this is
exactly what this gentleman said I'm going to quote him protection of this oak is not a guarantee
that's what he said I'm quoting him believe him he doesn't care about this he doesn't care about
the Kish people you know what he cares about is his deep pockets that's all he cares about that's
all these people care about and I'm pointing at them that's what they care about turn around people
turn around and remember who we are we are a community we love each other we respect each other
this is not right let's just think about it let's hold it for a little while let's revisit it
let's make it right and we can fix this we can fix this this is not a decision to be made today
this is a decision for us to come back together again along with with the union workers along with
the Kish along with city council and let's revisit let's let's give these Kish people more because
they deserve more you guys are Kish the Kish tribe you guys are settling for pennies
don't do it
good evening council members and mayor thank you for allowing me to speak
thank you to everyone who showed up tonight my name is victor Ramirez I'm the eldest daughter of
Petley vet supply I am also marine a rough a rough I've been in the Marine Corps for five plus
years now my dad is a Marine and Petley vet is veteran owned and operated I was born and raised
here and I do not stand for this I am for development but come on now come on this decision people is
probably already made you guys probably already made up your minds checks have already been cut
decisions have already been made handshakes have already been shook that's facts am I right
are we just here just a couple questions for you developers where do you guys live if you don't
live here I believe you don't belong developing plans that benefit your pockets here mayor your
pockets benefit from this Leslie Brian Chris Willie Armando do your pockets benefit
from these development projects who is cutting these checks where you guys benefit from this because
Petley vet and every other member of the city we're not benefiting from this who is cutting you
these checks and why are you guys being such sellouts to the quiche nation how much are you getting paid
for and why would you expect so little return for the potential devastation caused of their ancestral
medicine plant shame on you developers shame on you developers shame on you guys do you want to
live next to a warehouse I'm sorry for fulfill fulfillment plant that's what it's called it's not
it's not a warehouse would you want yeah you don't you don't want to live there you don't want to
raise your children there I'm sorry I'm sorry if my opinions you don't like them how many people
want to raise their children next to a warehouse I'm sorry fulfillment plan they can't even pronounce
the the plant the plant that that were that were destroying this
this I can speak I'm sorry when do we put our foot down when do we stop bending over backwards
for these developers when we put our foot down and stop letting these big money developers profit
from our land someone should probably look into the corruption of this city someone should probably
look into it I'm sorry Amanda Ramirez hello good evening I'm Amanda Ramirez I was born and raised here
in Herpa Valley and if you don't know my parents Veronica Hurtado Roberta Ramirez on the feed store
just across the street I wanted to come up here and speak on behalf of the younger generations
that will have to grow up here and face the consequences to the decisions being made it's quite apparent
that the majority of you council members are for a lack of better words in bed with these
outside developers and don't have better interests for the people incorporated in these plans being
here today has really opened my eyes to the fact that you don't care about our communities and what
we want we come in here and make it clear that we aren't on board with going through with these
proposals but at the end of the day we all know you have already made your decision and unfortunately
that decision will harm the foundation we have built here thank you we'll say Garcia
mayor councilman everybody here tonight it's a long night um I want to apologize because we are we're
all different opinion we have different interests here but we're forgetting we're a community and the
community comes together we need to stop the name calling the finger pointing all this
developers by land and they're able to develop develop other land if their plans come out right
this developer has gone beyond to include everybody everybody when I hear oh we're not going to be
able to afford these houses we we got to understand what's going on with our generation with right
now we've all grown our bridges that's why we need housing and people that live here will move up
into that housing and the lower housing will become available for the rest of the community
when people come here and point fingers at me as a union worker it's wrong because I'm a community
member I'm a tax paid member and my union doors are open to all in this community to give them
opportunity to give them a living wage to be able to open a home to be able to buy a home up there
to be able to start a business opportunity is roaming through here they've included
the indigenous people to take care of their own their own if we all really cared of what is going
on take a look around take a look around who orders our online I don't I'm a short fat guy and it's
hard to get close so I'm the guy that's missing them all and the swap me because that's the way
I used to go shop but nobody does that no more and they forget that they are the main cause to this
that's why we get truck traffic because nobody wants to go to retail everybody wants it to their
door and we forget that that's happening we got to always include too that everything's getting
better electrification of vehicles everything's coming the plan out there beautiful they've worked
with staff it's it's a slap in the face to staff that has spent so much time you guys that have this
heavy decision on your shoulders to be offended I'm sorry for everybody but we're all high strong
it's just my opinion but these people have been here a long time the infrastructure money
the tax base everything that will come to the the valley of harupa please please support it thank you
man as far as how you doing I've talked here before and stuff out seeing the plans
regarding this this project you know they've done a lot also though but there's a lot we need
to protect and stuff this decision is not going to be taken lightly in front of you guys and based
on the city council the way it is I you know in my opinion I don't know if I should you know
if I should ask or if you guys agree to it that you wait until after the election until the new
council is in because this decision should not be lightly let the people of the area vote either
for or against this I respect the fact that they they've made done a lot to see about protecting
the area they've done a lot to see about you know allowing progress for the area and we need to
embrace things like that but we also need to conserve and protect also our environments areas
based on certain things you know there's a lot on this decision and I ask that maybe this decision
needs to be waited about two or three months thank you okay so I do not have any more speaker
cards up here are there any last oh good evening council first of all my condolences to
Armando and I'm glad that your wife is seeking the treatment and we did miss you so I do live
in the neighborhood of where this proposed project is from my front door I can look out I see the
mountain the truck traffic is really going to be coming from Bloomington and Fontana because
they're building those huge warehouses right down the street from us and Armstrong Sierra that's
their truck traffic this proposed development when I first moved in 25 plus years ago I was already
expecting it to come it didn't come and I'm glad because I don't like the proposed the the approved
project the new project I was opposed to that as well but I attended a couple of the community
meetings and I spoke to the developer and I didn't believe half of what he had to say so I went back
to the meeting again and got more answers and I still didn't believe what he had to say so I
contacted the city I contacted the fire department I contacted the school board and I contacted the
police department until I got the answers that made sense to me and once I started learning more
about the project it's a good project and for people to come up here and and to dismiss the
Keish nation when you want us to protect your equestrians come on the Keish nation this is their
land this is their land I support you with the equestrians I don't support you with cock fighting
I don't support you with your back with your backyard rodeos and and things that are illegal I don't
support that but but I do support but I do support the Keish nation and allowing them to keep their
their traditions the way they see fit not the way I see fit it's the way they see fit and I do
support you on the equestrians you need to support them on the Keish nation
plain and simple you can't have it both ways Armando if you want us to respect you you need to
start respecting other people yeah we have one more Franco Pacheco I'm not sure I can read that
right thank you mayor and council my name is Franco Pacheco with inland valley alliance for
environmental justice I just got off of work right now and I was watching this on live so I came by
to show my support against the warehouse development that's being proposed for this project I want to
make it clear that richland communities the developer they have multiple warehouses multiple
projects here in Riverside County so when they say that they're losing jobs they have a lot of jobs
here we fight them on warehousing and multiple places all over Riverside County and the issue
that's happening here we see it all over Riverside County and just by watching the other speakers
I want to congratulate everybody that came out to speak and come together as a community to
oppose the project the plans for Riverside County for a long time by most elected officials have
already been to put warehousing wherever they can because we are strategically important for
this developer so everybody from Garupa to Paris to Mid Valley to Nuevo to Tomesco we all need to
come together and we need to put our foot down because over in this year alone we have 12 million
square feet of warehousing being proposed in one city of Paris I'm not sure in Garupa how many
more square feet is going to be added Riverside County there's millions of square feet of warehousing
already approved for the area so putting more warehousing in an area that's already oversaturated
is just gonna worsen a lot of the issues that we have now
if the developer can take out the warehousing component and put something else and you know
further guarantee the protection of the oak that would be great and we would like to hear it so
I agree with one of the previous speakers that maybe you guys need to put a continuance on this
ahold and go back to the board and see what kind of solution that the city of Garupa and the community
members can come to thank you thank you very much all for the speakers we have no more speakers
what we will do is go ahead and bring back the developer for a five-minute rebuttal
Brian Arty with Richland just wanted to hit a few points and leave a little time for Jeremy too
but we've been at this for seven years me personally I mentioned a planning commission my
daughter was born when I started working on this project and now she's in first grade
we've had countless workshops countless meetings countless discussions countless changes to the
plan working with staff meetings hours and hours and hours of listening and almost everything we've
done we've heard we've listened to and we've done we've consulted with Keish nation on the tree
the ones that are most important and most impacted by this tree and this this polymer oak is so
important to them we've been working with them for years on how to move the project forward
and still preserve their culturally significant facilities out on our open space
nobody at that time has come up to us and asked for interest in the area or any other group
or party has and I don't know that anyone was here at the open session talking about the
polymers oak for the last few years when we've been working with the Keish nation on this project
and they've been working with us and they are the ones that are most affected by this
small business I just want to hit on that the majority of this project is set up for small
business there's more land dedicated to small business and flexible space small tenant
then there is the light industrial the light industrial cannot be logistics with another
point of us listening we heard after having multiple workshops and coming into a planning
commission and a city council workshop and again this was about year three or four of my seven years
and we changed the plan and backed off of that tact because we listened that project in the
light industrial we we are now modeling it off another project that we're doing in Chino
that has an in and out corporate facility there that has significant amount of jobs they process
food there they distribute it there it's one of their corporate offices it's a shining jewel
for the city of Chino and that was a richland project and that's one of our richland partners
and that's the groups that we work with in terms of the housing costs the old plan is a lot of large
very expensive homes the new plan has a mix of housing from affordable attainable type products
entry level you know young couples professionals that can afford these homes and go move up
on to the more expensive homes it also has apartments and high density it has also a component of
a required affordable component of seven percent of the units that have to be affordable or an
in luffie that is significant so that's what I I have to say for now and then I want to turn it
over to Jeremy so he can have a few minutes to thank you everyone for your evening I know this
is a lot of time and I appreciate it thank you all just close with a couple words and just want to
thank again the community members who have shown their interest I appreciate the ones who are
talking about the reconciliation of a community I believe a community like what is being proposed
actually provides a lot of that we are offering the tribe and operate the kitchenation tribe and
opportunity to really get involved with the community even greater than they are today that
is a healing part of a project like this we've talked about time in the time I've been involved
in the project the time that project's been around since 92 we've talked about times since Brian's been
here and then we also talked about some time that a community member offered to give his free
time for a thousand hours that pales in comparison to what the kitchenation and their members have
been involved with as far as this area the community and the broader area they have committed to
being involved with this project and the maintenance of resources that are critical to them and to the
community they will not just show up they will commit time well beyond a thousand hours well
beyond probably millions of hours because we're looking in the long term we're not looking short
term like many of the people that you've heard from opposing the project this is a permanent
decision but it is also one that has a permanent solution for maintenance of important resources
for the area we've been honored to be a part of the community through this we know that we have a
good partner with the kitchenation and we know that this project has all the planning approaches
that are going to be appropriate for this area and and thinking about the adjacent neighbors in
the Crestmore community this time and at all the actual residents in the area and well beyond
it so I want to thank you council for your consideration it's been a long evening and look
forward to the discussion later but there being but there being no further comments I will now
close the public hearing and then bring it up for deliberation up here anybody like to go first
I'll go first go ahead thank you all for coming out and sharing your comments and concerns on this
it's really impactful project usually when we have projects when they come in they you know our
staff gives a presentation we get to ask for questions to our staff and then the public the
developer gets to come in and rebuttal and add a little bit of their presentation and then we open
the public hearing for the residents to speak up and then again it goes back to the developer and
they can answer the questions and now it comes back to us so we can talk to staff and then go back
and forth with developer that's why a lot of the times we wait to hear from everyone before we put
in our two cents that was for a Veronica because you were concerned that we didn't make a comment
before but okay Joe is this project going to be part of the inclusionary housing yes it will okay
how much of the arena numbers are recovering there well in terms of affordability the inclusionary
housing ordinance would require 7% of the actual units to be affordable and that comes out to I
believe around 119 units at various affordability levels including very low income the developer has
the opportunity to provide an in-loop fee rather than provide on-site units that is based on the
city's ordinance of two dollars and fifty cents per square foot you're talking about a lot of
units out there so it's perhaps seven and a half million dollars that the city would
if the developer selected that option that the city would retain in a fund that the city could
then use to leverage and participate with other affordable actual housing developers and provide
affordable housing within the community okay thank you for that one for the inclusionary housing
what about the arena numbers I know that we are using these numbers right to fulfill our arena
numbers yeah so when the so first of all the city's housing element is in full compliance with the
state we were one of the first cities in California actually to get a certified housing element that
includes arena so we are in full compliance with the regional housing needs assessment requirements
of the state and the actual existing specific plan that the numbers of those units were actually
unfolded into the current housing element however if this project is approved because of the type
of unit mix that is now being proposed you have a wider range of unit mixes including highest
density residential it will actually support our attempts to achieve our arena numbers particularly
in the very difficult to achieve highest density category so I think we have the numbers available
and I can pull those up but but that's the summation of it so if it doesn't get approved we would have
to rezone parts of the city to look for these numbers we would not have to rezone at this point
because the current inventory and the current number of units in our arena housing inventory
within the the housing element that contains a buffer right now so if this project is not approved
we would not be in a position to having to rezone any properties so if approved can we remove some of
those from the buffer that's of real possibility because that would then increase the amount of
buffer that we have particularly in some of those affordability categories and then it would enable
the councils to then perhaps go back and look at other sites that were previously designated as
high-stensity residential and actually address or change the zoning on those because we would have
a buffer that would sustain that okay that's it for now yeah just a clarification on
on the housing aspect Joe before I make some final comments in terms of arena so I know there's a
section of very high density in this project how many acres is that or maybe Jim you might you might
know that how many acres of very high density do we have in this project it's like 12 I think
or 20 it's well it's I'd have to look it's probably it's not
ton I can check it out well we could look for it but 21.7 acres 21.7 acres and and that would
sorry go ahead for a total of 543 units 543 21 acres and that's the very high density right
okay great and then the arena numbers one of the things we've discussed here before is they're used
the rezoning parcels are used as a proxy right so really at the end of the day they only count
towards arena numbers if the units are actually within the price range of affordability isn't that
right sure so perhaps I can speak to it so I would characterize it as well first of all I think
this is nuanced so when we talk about arena it's important to note that cities are not responsible
for providing the housing the obligation of cities are to provide zoning that would allow for that
type of development and that type of housing to occur the city has met that obligation but it is
true that when a when a site that is for instance zoned highest density residential is developed
and developed in a way that they are not affordable units the city is then
either we we lose the the the tally basically of those as affordable units and therefore
one of two things happens either we have a buffer that can absorb that and no action is taken
and needed by the city or if that buffer is eroded then the city might be in a position to have to
rezone property it's called the no net loss provision that we that the city may have to rezone
property to then make up for the loss of those particular units got it thanks Joe so so basically
the way I understand it we're rezoning these areas and and we have the zoning to qualify for the
overall arena but unless the actual units are built in accordance to the the income category so
basically unless it's actually affordable then it doesn't count we have to continue to rezone
until we reach the affordability so all the very high density parcels out in vernola and all those
that were zoned to the highest density that were then built as luxury apartments and super
expensive those don't count towards that number we have to find additional place and we could keep
going until we mandate until we ensure that affordable housing is actually built and I have a question
and I don't know if we know this but the affordable housing in Luffy would be 7.5 million
or they'd build 119 units that message to either Brian or Jeremy have you all decided which one
which way you're going to go to are you going to build the 119 affordable units or would you
pay the in Luffy we don't have an approved project at this point so we don't know okay when we get
our we are having that not gotten that far well when you save money if you just pay the in Luffy
approximately it's about sixty thousand dollars per unit not necessarily we've built them before
on other projects where it did make sense to build them you know that it depends on where
what some of these grants are we look at every opportunity so we'll look at that okay how would
it make sense for you to build actual affordable housing well is it getting grants uh the tax
bearing with affordable developers that would come on site we've done it on other projects up
in northern California got it okay okay great maybe we can work on that um thank you Brian yeah
so I think um yeah I just wanted to respond to that I'll I have other comments but I wanted to
keep the conversation going so real quick so good I do want to make sure that we understand
the facts and I think some people will because of the way the zoning was and the way the zoning is
can be confusing for some folks and I think it's important that everyone understands how it works
so middle of my was used as hey it's own light industrial that's a warehouse so this is my industrial
this is a warehouse middle of my was owned like industrial under county county allowed the heavy
industrial warehousing now that that light zoning has stayed but at that time those uses were allowed
we have since removed those uses from my industrial because the major parts of the city including
pedally flanavon sunny slope many areas were zoned heavy industrial by the county we took a very
long process about two years ago we called it the truck uh the truck intensive use ordinance
and we froze all the land so we could remove all the county had because the county had warehousing
planned everywhere so the warehouse that was planned that was already built to me that alone we
couldn't do anything about it and the council prior to us due to some lawsuits and I believe
Kamala Harris is part of that was to create these warehouse overlays so nothing outside those
warehouse overlays can be approved for distribution and there is a difference and I've always been
very clear about it what my job is so this site and I'd be and I've shared this too and this like
like Jeremy and Brian have said and many residents have said the Keats Nation has said this has been
a long process there's been many public hearings I've been sharing about it for years they actually
came was it four years ago maybe where you're like hey I want to do warehouses and we showed
you the door really quickly um you came back and what we've looked at and some residents have
actually keyed in on it is look we need housing I know there's a lot of opinions on housing but we
also need job centers we can't have just housing where people just leave and and work somewhere else
these are all small businesses this is business parks there's some in pedally there's something
in Glen Avon there's something rubido some of you that spoke you actually own small businesses in
these types of centers you don't see distribution fulfillment it is there is a difference there really
is and I know it can be hard when you have like Fontana and Paris and those cities that are just
railing warehouses we've done the different and a lot of EJ groups have recognized that
it's been very well documented and how we've done that differently so I really want to make
sure that we understand that what is in Milaloma what is in the far east of rubido that was county
and yes it's on let industrial that was their uses back then they allowed that heavy use we
have since removed it this area is specific it is just job centers you can have little shops
like barber shops and pool supply stores and there's you know yoga places and restaurants and
delis it's all that that kind of thing it's not big bad Amazon I agree Amazon is bad
so I really want to make sure that's clarified because and I also can understand where the confusion
can be all right now CFDs another good good comment every single community pays for its own
construction we can argue that that system sucks and well that's capitalism in our country all right
so every community that gets streets sidewalks trails proper and everyone's seeing all the new
communities like river bend and serrano oaks and dill soul and they have very nice amenities
those residents paid for them none of us that already live here paid for them or will pay for
them those residents only pay for them now if there's another mechanism in this country that we can
change great but right now it's not that's the that's the system we all live in so we need more
police we need more fire we as a council created a new public safety CFD yes those new residents
in this project or vernola or the district or any other housing project they're going to pay for
all of our additional fire and additional police the only other option is to raise our own sales
tax on ourselves or special tax on our properties I don't see that happening anytime soon
so we are one wanting to bring the amenities the services that you need this is the only legal
mechanism that we have if you guys have better ideas and we've shared this like later on the
agenda we have a whole bunch of CFDs and we've passed these CFDs over and over again we've never
made a secret of how these things get funded i get i get asked on social media or in person
or via email how who pays for this and why don't i have this well because you don't pay for it
you have no CFD or you're a more established neighborhood that already exists compared to
the new neighborhood where now there's CFDs to maintain all that you know again we don't have
to like it it is the way that our system and under the capitalistic system works you know and going
back to the light industrial i'm hoping now that you understand that by definition and by use it's
not distribution warehouse heavy industrial i'm in no way saying that there's not going to be some
truck trips there's always truck trips these are less impactful for those of you that again own
businesses in those this could be cyber centers is the trucks different than the trucks and meet
a loma i would venture to say yes but it is still totally okay to say i don't like job centers i
would rather have old housing and to pinpoint on what masaki said because i do like what he said
this project did create more high density what that allowed is more land 500 plus acres to be given
to the key station because the original plan is old housing are one large lots less open space
when you condense and put people in the i know it's going to sound counterproductive to some of
you guys i know you guys don't like some of this when you put people in a tighter spot with less land
and you know newer and newer generations are liking this because i don't want to mow their
lawn and all that fun stuff but that's a little hot take um when you when you build less land it's
gonna be less costly more affordable more open land to allow to enjoy parks and and whatever
the key station has planned and one last thing i might have more comments later uh when uh chief
i think i sorry if i forgot you know the the name and i don't want
any i wanted to say this but i wanted to wait and i didn't ask questions before this because
most of the questions i i know the answers to there's no reason for me to ask staff but
it is very important that everyone focuses on the polymer oak uh and it is important but there
are other sites that are more important to the to the first nation's people and all of it are
is important so i want to make sure that we understand that we we've been looking at one spot which
is important but there's a lot involved in that project so for now that's it thank you
so thank you Chris because you did answer a lot of the questions i was gonna ask staff
especially to clarify the difference between the warehouses in middleoma and the and the current
one so so a lot of the reason why there was a lot of um seem like secrecy i guess i would say
would go to the key station was because a lot of the sites you didn't want people to know about
is that correct yes okay so i want to make sure it wasn't people know that we weren't trying to
hide that it was in respects to your first nation um having your your first nation's
speak gave me peace knowing that you guys are in support of it because this is a very controversial
project so with that said knowing that the stewards of the land are are in favor
um i did see it in the beginning like oh it could be a this or that project in the beginning but
listening to you speak more it made me see that you guys feel there's more of a press for time
now that the site has been exposed more publicly than it had before um and it makes me understand
more um the support and why you you you want these protections now more than i guess before so
thank you for that for clarifying those things when you came up and spoke um i'm glad this project
also brought a lot to the table brought you know uh key station first nation economic development
housing all under one and you guys managed to work it out which is very rare to hear i've
here in other cities there's it never really happened so i'm glad to see that you guys all sat
at the table um and did and worked something out so i believe um i i'm i lean in favor of this of
this project because of the one i'm in favor of the jobs i'm in favor of the housing and i'm favor
the key station so i mean i i lean towards in favor of this project so that's some of the
stuff i have to say for right now thank you thank you i think i'll be doing everybody a favor i did
not take notes tonight which is a never but fortunately my brain still works so um i will
just rattle off a couple things first uh to people that may misunderstand or misconstrue
uh specifically to the Ramirez family um there's no checks that have been cut in my direction
there is nothing that i have as an advantage to approve or not approve any project by any developer
and and i sit here as i always do trying to make sure that whatever gets approved is a good project
and i actually like this project i think the design is well done um
and that's all i'm going to say on the good side right now so let me flip to the other side
my problem with this project and my leaning at this time toward uh not voting yes but but uh to
either vote to put it on hold or to deny it is based on this tree this bush the oak i have
first of all i should say that my planning commissioner Arlene Pruitt and i met with the tribe
here at city hall a month or so ago they came in after the planning commission hearing so we could
understand more about them and more about what they would offer and and how they would be looking at
protecting the oak uh and i believe they they could be the right fit my problem with this whole thing
is lack of information i asked simple questions to staff and and um and to others who potentially
could could have provided me some insight and and some of those questions were simple all right
you you're telling me that the the roots only go 30 feet deep or the roots don't spread wide i said
okay so how do you know that a 400 or 500 or a thousand or a 2,000 foot buffers enough how do you
know you won't dig it up because you don't want to hurt anything i said well if you're telling me
that based on historical data that oak trees have a certain width of a root structure and you're
telling me that it's no bigger than two or three times the the width of the the bushes on top
whatever you call it the canopy of of the tree well so if you know that then dig up a hundred feet
past it see if there's any roots see if there's something you find a little root then stop digging
don't destroy the the trees nobody's going to do that they won't touch it and so i'm sitting here
and i've been you know usually i'm i'm pretty well ready to make a decision and on this one i have
been feverishly sweating as you'll probably all are in this hot room not sure where this was going
to go and not sure where my direction would be but i i certainly believe that we need to have more
details i i i can tell you this this tree to me i'm a blip in the in the moonlight to this oak tree
18,000 years i'll be here what if i'm lucky 80 if i'm lucky okay tomorrow i'll be gone somebody
else will be here you know all of us will be gone at some point the tree will still be here or our
goal is to make sure it's still here and it's way bigger than i am i'm a little tiny pebble
compared to this and i am certainly not going to be the one that's going to vote a project in
where i don't have enough facts or details about whether or not it's the right move i
absolutely want protection for it and i think the stewards the quiche nation would be the right
the right people but i i can't consciously vote yes on a project where i don't know
if we have enough space dedicated and and unfortunately we won't know that tonight
i'm not sure how we get to that answer and and of course with with with the no no no we won't
disturb anything the only thing i can consider is well maybe and and fortunately some of you tonight
are our experts in these fields uh who spoke and i appreciate that i believe that yes we have a
consultant but even our consultant uh staff had had advised that they're using data from
joke correct me like a hundred years old data or something like that or whatever it was that
they figured out the root structure i can't remember how old it's from i don't recall the paperwork
that they looked at not real digging up trees to to do and you can't dig up a a tree that's anywhere
close to this so we don't know that the the literature review the literature review yeah
you know to me that was a joke and and i'm and i'm sorry but it doesn't cut the mustard i don't
have any more puns i'm sorry but the point is is that it's not enough and as i said i like the
project i think it's good but until we have additional information there's no way i'm supporting it
not tonight and i'm not saying you know to the developer you're out a lot forget it what i'm
saying is we need some additional insight and intel on on the tree and and yes there may be
additional sacred sites which the tribe has expressed uh and and that's that's fine but let's put it this
way i have and certainly i i i know many of them must have been a i generated but in the last five
days i've gotten over 2,850 emails which i can't read all of them because they're all
save the oak or or don't save the oak and they're all ai generated emails so the real emails mixed
in there i don't know who's his who's so it's been tough to try to even analyze there's just
no feasible way to go through all that uh so yay to the ai world because they're really
disrupting what a normal process would be to figure out what our real residents and people
really interested are talking about and now we're we're looking at a bunch of you know
general auto-generated crap and and unfortunately i i don't take all that i can't absorb all that
nor can my colleagues i'm sure so we're we're looking at what you know was in front of us who
we've spoken to about it and i i could probably babble but it's 1130 at night so
i i i would only say that aside from if this got approved tonight i i still have an issue with the
fact that they want to wait for 600 units to sell before the parks are even you know required to
be put in that that to me is junk uh but aside from that i i can't support it with what i know
at this moment so hopefully uh maybe we could hit the pause button and and bring some experts in
that know a whole lot more than i do and can educate the rest of us on uh these kinds of things
or or come up with a way so we can figure out a legitimate buffer that protects and saves the
environment the tree the other sacred sites and the last thing i will say is that
one of the first slides if i'm not mistaken or a slide that was shown i think in the staff report
or or characterization maybe that i believe uh happened was this site claims maybe i'm mistaken
but did this site claim that there was going to be trails and walking in open space because
the 500 acres will be in this proposal will be turned over property rights will be turned over
to the tribe and if that tribe so then the quiche nation so chooses they could fence everything
off and not provide access and so if this development is purporting that there's a lot of open space
and trails those may not ever be open to them or to the public at all so i don't understand that
part of it and maybe there's some more clarity that we can have on that but again it's not going to
change my decision it's just something else that that i think is a missing link that we need to
understand and that's all i have for now i have a question i wanted to ask um joe earlier he had
mentioned about the parks being built after 600 homes being built is that something that can be
changed um absolutely that is under the discretion of the city council okay um okay can we start
looking at that maybe every something reasonable maybe do the parks first and then the home every
hundred homes so um jim if you can just address there there's we would be talking about two different
things it's the major park and then it's the pocket park so there's a two different um that
councilmember bergsen had had mentioned so we can address what is in there and then perhaps get some
direction from the council in terms of what your preference is yeah i think when you mentioned
earlier about the parts being built after the 600 homes was a big concern so we want to make
sure that i mean i'm now we're going to be putting some input on this making sure that the parks
are being built at the same time or before the homes are being built yeah the specific plan says
that the community park must be built in the first phase and it has to be open to the public by the
600 unit so that clearly you could you could vary that to uh sooner you know trigger time um then
then it goes on to say that all the other parks the community parks within the planning areas
need to be developed and open by the 75th percent of the units within that planning area
so the smaller parks could conceivably be built in a lot less units are complete
because if a planning area only has a hundred units then 75 would have to be done and the park
would have to be open okay so those are the pocket parts being built at the same time so
by the time the 75th house is built then the pocket park is built or open the yeah the community
0% the PA smaller parks the five of them need to be developed with each PA and it has to be done
once 75% of the units are complete so PAs will have varying you know unit sizes they might be
200 units they could be 100 units but whatever it is 75% of those then it opens up and that's
pretty typical of planning communities to you know not require the park until there's enough
people to actually even about the one the major part the public part the 600 homes can we change that
so yes the larger community park with the you know the ball fields you know the soccer fields
and probably have you know ASU type sports and things there can that be changed to less homes
being built maybe about 200 homes I would say that this is again the purview of the city council
to determine but it if we're talking about a significant change the council may want to
at least receive some input from the applicant to to at least address that and respond to that
do you guys want to respond so there's a third leg to this tool stool too and that's jrpd
we've had a significant amount of discussion with them about the timing of the park too
there needs to be enough units to support the park financially and to use the park
there's also the other project right next door that we sold to linar shadow rock that has a
significant park facility that's there so the timing for that to all work and have enough
units to support the park was discussed with jrpd at length in terms of like these parking
parks in the planning areas in the parking parks we could certainly look at moving that up a little
bit like 50th percentile or something like that but in terms of the park I mean you know 500 units
seems reasonable without having to go back to jrpd you know but they are a part of this too
because the ultimate will be taken on you also don't want to only have enough homes you know if
if the market changes and and conditions changing you know you know four or five hundred homes
that can't support the it financially it's a problem for jrpd they need to have enough units
there financially so okay um joe uh so i'm gonna make some savings you're gonna
just ask you so um how many consultants were involved in the studies for the past four
three four years too many
for the tree specifically that area yeah quite a few um so we have uh first carbon solutions and
they have a whole team of you know in-house people that are biologists and archaeologists
and off hand i'd say at least and then we had some consultants to do the studies
so there's probably like each stakeholder had their own different different consultants then
there's the applicants consultants who provided reports and then we had peer reviews of their
reports when they were so there wasn't just like and just kind of going back to one one comment
where it was one consultant and paid by the developer and worked with the developer that's not
the case they do have theirs but we had different ones the quiche nation i believe
also had some input and in the consultants that were looking at all this and studying it
all right that's why i want to make sure anything actually i just wanted you to confirm it two
tribes involved in the consultation so boba and quiche and they had their own biologists and
archaeologists and so forth as well all right so to my colleague
say you know if you don't trust the quiche nation with their own land that's fine
so i'll say the following you know it's not about trusting the quiche nation it's about
making sure that they have the right amount of land to do their to do their protection and again
that's an unknown so throwing out numbers well their studies have have are based on
literature they're not based on fact they're not but that was that was the argument
the studies of the root is is based on literature i mean i think it seems like we're guessing at
best right because we haven't we haven't looked specifically at at the root
we're basing it off of academic literature other shrubs that are not as old right
and using those as examples for this one so i i think look when when these projects come up
it's important for us to think about is this the best that we can do
for some people yes that's going to be the best that they can do
the the this area in rubro and and my my biggest concern i think the housing
i think we can make the housing work right i think i think that makes sense to an extent
right we can build beautiful communities that have the the necessary density right
my concern on the housing is the affordability right there's this
magical thinking that because there's more just the prices will go down right that's the
the magical hand of capitalism you know and and law you know it logically it would make sense
but that's just not the reality right you build more housing more people come in
people keep them vacant force to to raise to artificially inflate prices right these are
things that are happening all over the country all over california
so i really want us to think about the affordability aspect how do we make sure
that these housing units are going to be affordable for multiple generations right that
we're not just taxing them into oblivion and to pay for the profits that are going to be made
off of the project i think that my biggest concern is the the industrial yes it's light industrial
right warehouses and logistics are prohibited
but that's a that that doesn't limit the impact that it's having in that area the 814 trucks a day
that doesn't limit it right and i know chris you mentioned that nothing outside of the overlays
can be approved for warehouses that's true but then we create new overlays
right to allow more warehouses just like we did in the district right so so there's
there's big concern as to the precedent that we're setting in continuing to expand
the industrial aspects the truck impacts the truck trips right in this community particularly
rubidal as a whole is designated as a warehouse and industry center right for the city little
there's more and more warehouses manufacturing centers that are creating
truck trips and trucks truck uses that are congesting that area that are designating
that community which is primarily Latino to have to face with to have to face those every day
right folks that are walking home folks that are living in those communities none of us want to live
in across the street from major warehouses and industrial centers
i i appreciate the the engagement of of the quiche nation of the native american community
and i do agree as has been said that it's crucial for us to protect
cultural resources and the environmental resources i i just feel that the message we'd be sending
with this particular project is is a negative one not not because of the involvement of you
i think that's crucial i think i i think they should give you the land right now without this project
and so my problem is that it's being used as a bargaining chip to get you all on the table
and and and that's wrong we haven't fought uh for for so long to be leveraged right and i i i don't
want to see our brothers and sisters a native american community continue to be lever especially
by uh massive corporate developers to build an industrial building 500 feet away from this
sacred site um you should have unfettered full access to this land right that's without question
um but using uh your access to this land as a as a bargaining in bargaining chip in exchange
for another warehouse in uh in this community um that that's just sending a message to the world
that is that we can be leveraged as a community that we can be leveraged as multiple communities
that are coming in on this and and uh you know i don't think that's right i think we need to stand
against that um i think we can stand together against that type of of dynamic right this is a
negotiation right um and you all know that that now there's there's a lot of support for you all right
so how do we make sure that you get a better deal right that it's not just um you know
two million square feet of industrial buildings 500 feet away from the sacred storage and and from
from the sacred sacred tree um with massive other cultural uh items that are likely in in the other
500 acres right so i think we we need to take that into consideration i think again based on the
studies that we got i agree with council member brogson i think it's it feels like we're guessing
even even our our our expert didn't seem to know um what was going on he couldn't explain correctly
what what was happening with the rock structures and and the roots um you know we're guessing at
best we're guessing the size and the length of our roots i think anything that we can that we do
that impacts it with is a desecration to to to our community to to the world really
um i think the community development agreement is weak um you know i think we make it seem like
the developers forking up 22 million dollars they're giving 1.8 right the majority of that is coming
from taxpayers right coming from our residents i think i think we need a stronger negotiation
there um the the 200 million dollar in fees that includes the CFDs it includes the taxes from residents
and the rest of it is standard construction fees um so i think that the the environmental impacts
are are pretty severe um we we have a statement it's called a statement overriding considerations
meaning that we've considered all the negative environmental impacts and we're we're signing off
on this statement to override i override all the negative impacts uh it's just a way for us to justify
the negative environmental uh and and negative community impacts that are going to happen so
so uh i i don't think we have enough i i don't think this is a good deal as it is now i think we
should go back to the negotiating table i think we can get more for our residents
for the quiche nation and also for the tree so i have one last comment and it's it's going to
share just the timeline uh you're absolutely right since you mentioned some of this stuff
the district was one project where we actually did expand the overlay and in that one for the ej
groups that are here regi groups that are watching which you've been fighting for
in other cities for a thousand foot step back it's exactly what's in that project
including diverting traffic and all the community benefits now you've already know on that uh you
which is your right and one of your arguments at the time was can we just put it all as housing
we didn't we proved the way it was and then vanilla ranch came where we removed warehousing for
housing and you still oppose that one then we had the rubidal commerce park that's in rubidal
it is manufacturing um it's relatively near housing about 500 plus feet if i recall
uh and you again a good comment you thought that that was maybe too close for housing to be there
yet during the housing element you wanted to rezone the rubidal commerce park yes that's a
manufacturing yes with uh almost 300 trucks a day i know but i'm saying you're you had about
concern you didn't like the housing so close to it that was yeah because i don't want to build
our trucks correct correct but then during the housing element you wanted to rezone land
for apartments in an industrial center uh and then the other one that i had is trucks again we we've
talked about there's very many different kinds of trucks um yes we don't like the diesel sign
we know that we have truck routes we're working on some other improvements but if i recall
when we were trying to relegate and manage trucks in residential neighborhoods you had a call to
action to come everybody because we were coming for their trucks so do you not want trucks or do
you want trucks like it's it's different messaging yeah that that um that draft ordinance it
is there is there a collapse go ahead and clap yeah that's good it's good comment um yeah that draft
ordinance was was in complete it banned uh horse trailers it banned utility trailers it banned
duallys they bind all kinds of trucks it was it was unclear so yeah absolutely i called it out
i made a video to inform our residents and said hey you all need to take a look at this
um uh because i think it was important and yeah absolutely i voted against another warehouse in
rubidal i did i did i stood with most most of the residents in rubidal that are against uh more
trucks on rubidal boulevard uh just with those projects alone the district this one the rubidal
commerce park and a couple others you're looking at thousands of truck trips a day on rubidal boulevard
sure that's what that's what you guys are bringing to your residence in in rubidal my point is that
with every project you contradict yourself on what you're opposing and why that's all
yeah yeah i think i i i think i've been pretty consistent um i've stood against all those projects
because of what it does to the community uh because of its impact uh if you're looking at and i was
very clear in terms of vernola you're looking at luxury housing i mean they're the ones who funded
your campaigns how much money did they give you but think like sixty thousand dollars
uh you know that that's what that's what it was like i'm not you know not trying to be controversial
family here give you um not trying to be controversial so the family's here give you
they didn't give me sixty thousand dollars let's pull over you can we can yeah i mean campaign
that's all disclosures i mean your people are threatening me by email sending us letters and
sending us all kinds of other uh other uh messages to try to scare our community into submission
we're not going to allow you to do that uh we're not scared of you and and and there's people here
that have blatantly lied on at the dais and continue to lie that have received cease and desist
letters for their lives and for being misinformed and if they continue to do that then yes we will
continue to send cease and desist letters and continue to uh uh initiate litigation against
them if that's what's needed to end all these lies and all your buddies are spreading in our
community i don't know which buddies yeah no you hide it well are you guys done
hey this is the response we usually get when we call them out on his contradictions
yeah you get facts you get facts what is it it's on tape yeah what is it's a fact
you know i mean it's true Leslie you own a trucking company you benefit from having
thousands of trucks in rubidal i mean that's what that's what you all get i don't know for a warehouse
industry and i drive trucks myself and i'm very proud of them yeah that's great i love truckers
we have a lot of truckers in our community absolutely i'm proud of that i do have a small
freight company we operate three trucks out of the ports of long beach and go all the way to
Fontana not in her bevelli right you know because we don't have we don't have because of the zoning
changes and all the stuff that we have applied in our city to protect our city we don't have the
truck parking here we're not supposed to but my trucks are not parked here and i know you keep
bringing this up and you guys keep bringing up about filling pockets i have not received
anything from any of these developers so please stop with these accusations anyway
i'm going to go now with my comments on this project
we as a city we have been able to delay a lot of projects and have demanded meaningful
and intentional changes that include community benefit agreements we have done everything
environmental justice groups ask for and never get unless they sue those developers
we have continued to go above and beyond no other city has done in this region this is a really
hard decision but this is a responsible project that will bring benefits to all and the best part
is that we have the opportunity to make a president here and to give land back to the first peoples
so i want to make sure that in my lifetime i was able to do that so i want to give them back
their land their 13 sacred signs sacred sites over 500 acres so tonight i'm going to stand
with the cucinations okay so do we have any more to deliver it up here would anyone like to call
a motion i call a motion second it yes for the park outline those for you thank you mr.
thorsen so there was some discussion we just wanted to make sure that we captured the
city council's intent there's some discussion regarding the timing of park being available
and again we're talking about the major park and and the sort of the the pocket community
parks so we heard from the applicant this evening that they would they are open to reducing that
time frame for the major park from 600 units to 500 units and a reduction on the pocket parks
from i believe 75% to 50% okay so if that's and again that that's the proposal from the developer
that does not lock the council into that decision but i wanted to make sure that that issue was
addressed as part of the motion and so that's number one number two when we get to the item
regarding the introduction of the ordinance for the development agreement i do have some
language that i'd like to clarify in section 5.10 regarding the 325 000 that is that is proposed
to be dedicated to jrpd for youth activities equestrian uses and or new and existing parks so when we
get to that item we will be making a recommendation as part of that introduction and we will be
providing some proposed language at that time okay actually maybe you can give the language now
because i think they can adopt and introduce the ordinance all in one motion excellent i'd be happy
to do that so the language under section 5.10 should be replaced with the following language
5.10.1 owners shall make payment to the arupa area of recreation and park district jrpd in the
amount of 325 000 for the improvement of new slash existing parks and or equestrian amenities
and or youth activities that directly impact the communities of rubido and cenislope prior to
the issuance of the 500th building permit for the richland property so you make a motion again
peter and then wasn't there one more in the there was a list of changes in the yeah they were
included as part of attachment 8 that discussed the the issue regarding single story homes and
i believe there's a issue that we brought up that Jim presented on regarding a typographical
error that we would like addressed and again those i believe are in attachment 8
so we would we would recommend that the motion indicate those changes as well
we call a we had a motion and second to adopt resolution number 2024 dash 102 and 2024 dash 103
with everything that was stated yeah and then you can also introduce ordinance number 2024
23 that's for the development agreement okay so with that with 2024 dash 23 with the development
agreements you said yes that's the ordinance we have a motion and a second all in favor
oh wait the changes that mr. Perez just yes on the favor all right on the pose
three two peter can i ask you a question about the remainder of our agenda tonight
is there anything pressing that we couldn't push based on what time it is
yeah we would really prefer that we get these really prefer that we get these done tonight
okay if paul just says it's to see if they go to just there they're two c of d i know yeah well
let's go paul let's go then just don't have them give us a report unless somebody has got a question
is there a ballot to count go go go just go to the motions go to the motions can we
yep you have to open a public hearing so peter i mean paul don't need don't need uh
report we're gonna go right to the motion okay oh you got open the public hearing
um okay so please while we continue the rest of the meeting if we can please have everybody
keep it down
okay so we're going to open the public hearing for ida item c public hearing to consider calling
a special election declaring the result of the elections and approving formation and levy of
special taxes for the city over valley community facilities district number ps 2024 dash 007 public
safety troid court generally located at the south end of troid court and north of amber and
boulevard that's not d right no let's see okay you're right if i put hearing close it
so do we have any uh no public comments on that no okay we're going to close the public hearing
what's the proof second note all in favor hi hi hello yes we have to do the ballot
one hundred yes one dollar i've never heard of say no yep make sure your mind my use continues
Yes, one owner cast, one ballot, all votes were in speech.
Thank you.
Vicki, all abstain.
All abstain.
So we have an abstention from you?
Okay.
I did.
Les.
Do you continue?
Yes.
2-5.
So we're done.
It's resolution 2024-93, 2024-94.
And since Vicki opened the ballots and gave you the results, you can do 2024-95 and introduce
ordinance number 2024-20.
Okay.
You can do that in one motion.
So we can do it.
We'll do it.
So tabulate that ballot, right?
Yes.
That's correct.
That motion to approve?
Yes.
Second?
All ayes?
All ayes.
All in favor?
Aye.
Which one is all?
No, CFT.
C or D?
Still part of C?
So D is continued.
So D is continued and we're on to E. We'll open the public hearing for a public hearing to
consider calling a special election to the fair and the results of the election and approve
information of the levy and special tax for City of the Valley Community Facilities District
number PS20-22-003, public safety, Sacramento Heights, generally located northeast, north
of State Route 60, south of Canal Street, east of Opal Street and west of Pacific.
No public comments?
Okay, we'll close the public hearing.
Do we have, okay, close the public hearing and then we'll go to Ms. Waswell, do we have
a tabulation of the ballot?
Yes, one owner cast, one ballot.
All votes cast were in favor of the special taxes.
Thank you.
Can we have a motion and a second?
Okay.
Two, three, four, dash 99 and 20, 24, dash 100.
What's your proof?
Second?
Do we have a second?
Second.
All in favor?
Aye.
All vote.
All vote, all vote, all vote.
All opposed?
So we have one abstention and no vote.
No vote.
One abstention.
One abstent?
Yeah, yes.
We did them all right, Peter?
Yeah.
All right.
Go ahead and do not board a five.
Consul business.
Do we have any council business?
Wait, did you, I'm sorry, I, I did come here.
Oh, I thought you.
Excuse me.
Can we keep it down in the chamber, please?
On the first.
We did it absolutely, we did the ballot and we did everything.
We did the ballot and then we did everything.
You know we did the ballot.
I would, at this point since Vicki announced the results of the ballot, I would recommend
that you adopt the four resolution and introduce the ordinance in one motion.
Move.
Move to approve all forward the introduction of the ordinance.
Then we have a second from Leslie.
Second.
All in favour?
Aye.
So four ayes and one abstention.
Okay.
Good.
Yeah.
Are we done?
Then we go to council business.
No council business appears.
Okay.
City council request for future agenda items.
No.
Okay.
And then Mr. Thorson, may we have your report?
Nothing from you?
Okay.
No additional comments?
Would there be no additional further business?
We'll adjourn the meeting aye.
I'm going to adjourn it in the-
1208.
In the-
In the stand zone.
Do you want to adjourn it in-
I'm going to-
Oh yes.
What's your father-in-law's name?
Your father-in-law's name?
So we're adjourned in the memory of Cesar Huerta at 1209.
Next meeting is September 9, 2024, meeting 7pm at City Council Chambers 8930 Lyman Avenue
Herpa Valley, California 9259.